I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, Angela. Hey, good morning.
Good morning. You were telling me a tale as I was warming up my coffee this morning about your mascara. Well, here's the thing, you guys. I walked in, said, good morning to Sam, good morning to Jenna. Hi, to Matt on Zoom. I go to use the restroom. I have a massive mascara clump on my cheek. Nobody.
I didn't know it. I was in my own world, getting my coffee ready. Did you know? Apparently I didn't look up for my phone when you came in. Apparently not. But also, I guess Josh didn't notice when I said goodbye to him. I always give him a kiss goodbye. No giant black clump and mascara on my cheek.
But pretty much this morning has been a little. bit of a get ready fail. I slept with my hair wet, so you know what I woke up to. Your hair looks great for having slept with it wet. I tried to tame my hair all morning. It looks great. Oh, it's underneath. Don't look at the back. Okay. Whatever. Let it go. Let go the back of my head a long time ago. But then also, I will hold on to makeup way past the time you're supposed to hold on to it. Like my powder compact right now is just one tiny square that's left. Most of it is broken off. And then I will smush what's left of the powder. And then it, like, I'm not throwing that away. Well, I was doing this with my blush as well. And I, it had, I had dropped it once,
so I had a crack through it. And it was getting a little precarious, but I still kept finding a way to use it. And this morning, I'm rushing because my hair is crazy. And I grab that blush out of the drawer. And I open it, and all the inside of it has crumbled like a fine paper. And it went, all All over. But he's just like blushed confetti. All over the sink, all over the counter. I had to change my top. So I don't know what the lesson is, you guys.
Maybe just like when things are past their due date, let them go. You know, it sounds like my New Year's resolution about like little fixes big wins. Yeah. Like if you fix that problem, then it won't explode on you later. Maybe it's okay to toss that. very old blush. I think it's three years old. Well, you know, lady, my problem is that now I can barely see without my glasses. I cannot read at all. You know, I already worry about the apocalypse. Sure. I'm worried that I'm going to lose my glasses during the apocalypse, and then I'm not even
going to be able to read a book during it. Oh, that'd be horrible. Can you imagine? No. I worry that I'm going to be barefoot during the apocalypse, and it's going to be like die hard where he's running around barefoot trying to fight the bad guys. This is another one of my worries. Yes. Yes. Shoes and glasses, very important. Well, I can't see my face when I put my makeup on anymore. And it doesn't matter if I use one of those magnifying mirror things. It's not enough magnification. So every morning, when I do my makeup, then I put my glasses on and I see what I've done.
And it's never great. Do you have to tone it down? It's not the toning it down. It's like the eyeliner isn't in any way straight. It looks straight to me when I put it on in a blur. Right. Or I will have like gobs of mascara underneath my eye and I can't see them until I put my glasses on. So I have to do my makeup, then put my glasses on and then go in with like a wet Q-tip and like fix everything.
I wonder what we're going to look like when we're old ladies. Like legit old ladies. Like I think I'm going to have too much blush. Yeah, too much blush, too much lip. And you're going to have like a lot of mascara globs. Yeah. I can't wait. I can't wait.
I feel the same way. I don't mind. All right, should we get into our fan chit-chat question of the week? Yes. Should we also say what we're here to discuss today? I mean, we can. You guys, we're going to get to it. We're doing episode nine of the paper.
It's called matching ponchos. But first, let's have a chit-chat. This one's coming to us from Alexander G in College Station, Texas. Howdy, Jenna, and Angela. I'm Alexander G. from College Station, Texas. My question for you guys is, if you guys have not pursued acting,
what would Jal's career be? I'm very curious to know you guys' answer to this question and love the pod. Thank you guys. All right. Thank you, Alexander. I know. I thought that was such a thoughtful question. I've thought about this.
Yeah? I know my answer. Well, you should go. I think I would be a vet tech. Oh, you'd be such a great vet. tech. You have such a heart for animals, Jenna? Yeah, I mean, those were the two choices I was weighing when I was younger. I thought, do I want to become a veterinarian? Do I want to become a vet tech? Do I want to become an actor? Right before I got my job on the office, I had just started doing rescue work with
kitten rescue, and they teach you like a lot of vet tech kind of stuff, you know, giving medications, giving fluids, giving vaccines, being able to spot illnesses, things like that. There's a lot of in the rescue stuff. And I really loved it. So I called my manager Naomi and my acting coach Robert and I said, you guys, I think I might want to make a change. If something doesn't happen this pilot season, I think I want to take some time off. I want to go to two years of vet tech school. I just, the acting thing is feeling like just eight years of rejection. Like I'm just like that's no joke. It has worn me down. Yeah, it can be a real beat down. Yeah. And this other thing is giving me purpose. It's making me feel joyful. I feel needed and I feel good at it. And I want to pursue that. And then I'll know, like, should I go back to acting? But I might need to take like a sabbatical. Well, as we know, I ended up going out for the office and then everything sort of changed and that path was the one chosen for me. But I've continued to do the animal rescue work. I mean, I'm fostering kittens right now.
I mean, that's one of the first things I learned about you in our friendship. Yeah. You were fostering kittens the first time I went to your house. Oh, is that true? Yes. Oh, my gosh. That's right. We had a screening of the pilot of the office and I had foster kittens.
Yeah. I remember that. I've been fostering and socializing little feral kittens for over 20 years now, and I love it. So I think if I wasn't an actor, that's what I would do. And I think if I hadn't gotten cast on the office, I very well might be doing that right now. And I'm kind of doing it, kind of doing both. Yeah, you are. You found a space for both things in your life.
Yeah. What about you, Sam? Growing up, I really wanted to own a comic book store. But I was alive when everything went to Amazon. So, like, there's no real physical print media anymore. So you can't really have. There's like five existing comic bookstores left in Los Angeles. There's one in the valley.
Our son has been to. Yeah, the ones that I've been there have been going for like 30, 40 years now. But yeah, that's what I want to do. Sam, have you been to Secret Headquarters? I have, yeah. That's my home shop. I love Secret Headquarters. And so we're like, yeah.
Shout out to Secret Headquarters. It's a what all can you find there, Sam? Everything. They're really well stocked. They're up to date. They're really knowledgeable and really nice. Sam, I could really see you running a comic book store. I could too.
I could also see you back in the day running a video store. Yes. And knowing about like all the movies. and being able to suggest a movie. Yeah. Like the local one, like I know growing up, the town where I would go visit my grandparents, they didn't have Blockbuster, but they just had a guy that had started a collection and had his own little, like, store where you could go rent movies.
Yeah. I also grew up in a real small town in Wisconsin, so I didn't have that big of dreams. I distinctly remember seeing the movie Clerks and being like, oh, I could do this. Like, I could work an amenial job forever. But a creative one. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Matt, what about you?
I think high school history or English teacher. I think I might still want to do that one day. It's just like big shout out to teachers. It's such a grind and so hard and so kind of thankless. But I would love to do that one day. Oh, Matt, my mom was a history teacher, a middle school history teacher for over 35 years. Yeah, it's great. I think middle school would be tough.
Yeah. And Jenna's sister is a teacher and my sister's a teacher. Yeah. Lots of love for teachers here at office ladies. All right, Angela, what about you? Well, you know, growing up in Indonesia, a big part of my life was the ocean. And we'd go out to the Thousand Islands and it was my real happy place. I love to explore.
I just loved it. And my love for it has never stopped. And so often on for years, I thought maybe I would go into some type of marine biology. And then, you know, I always had the acting bug, but those were my two loves. And then since being out in California, I started working with Oceana, which is a nonprofit, trying to help save our oceans and protect them. But ocean preservation is really meaningful to me. So I think I'd do something with that, something about protecting these very fragile marine ecosystems.
And we need the ocean, you guys. We need it. We need to take care of it. So, yeah, I think doing something like that. Yeah. That's cool. I could see that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's interesting always to think about like your parallel universe life, like, you know, the movie sliding doors. Like what's that other version of you somewhere? I can see you somehow being a mascot for the ocean, for ocean cleanup for like the six-pack rings on you, like you cutting them. I could see you like teaching kids through song to cut those. Or straws go in turtles' noses. Yeah, exactly. Don't throw away that plastic bag. It looks like a jellyfish.
Exactly, yeah. Oh, it's already begun. There it is. You're mixing your improv performance with ocean preservation. There it is. And I did. I did a trip to Belize. You guys know with Rashida Jones.
I've talked about that to sort of highlight the barrier reef there. So, yeah. Well, thank you, Alexander. We love getting to talk about all that. I love that conversation. Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we'll discuss episode nine of the paper matching ponchos. All right.
We are back from break. It's time to take a break. talk about episode nine matching ponchos written by L.E. Correa and directed by Dave Rogers. Yes, Dave Rogers. And he gave us the best tidbits about this episode. Such good ones. I mean, listen, everyone we reach out to in the office universe has always been so amazing. But for like super specific details, Dave Rogers is like All-Star. A hundred percent. Give us a summary, Jenna. All right. Ned and mayor embark on a road trip to interview a possible cult leader. Meanwhile, Oscar seeks to confront his online troll and Esmeralda has fallen under the spell of a young photo of Barry.
This is, I think, my favorite episode. I think it's mine too. There's so many moments that I was like, I love this moment. Same. All right, we're going to start with a cold open. Ken and Travis are manning a Softys toilet paper slash ice cream truck. Ken is dressed as a milkman. Travis is dressed as Santa. And they're handing out what looks like to be ice cream cones. Did you see what was on the side of the truck? No, what? I mean, it was painted with the Softies logo and all that. It was painted pink and white with the Softies logo, like the Softies Lady that we've seen. But there was some signage, huge on the side. I had to freeze on it. It said, quote, by touching a cone, I waive any legal claims or rights. Oh, wow. So I kind of have to call BS on the parents that are letting their kids take these cones and they all bite into them thinking their ice cream. They look like toilet paper. They are toilet paper. They're little mini rolls of toilet paper on an ice cream cone.
They smell like mint, which is just what you're. you want to wipe your sensitive areas with. What? Yeah, this whole thing is they're sort of like goodwill way of trying to get the community to forgive them for the giant sewer clog that they caused. Yeah. And Marv put kin in charge of this sort of brand rehabilitation effort, right? I have questions. Oh, yeah. Number one, how much money did this company spend on this custom-painted ice cream truck and these tiny toilet paper rolls that fit on top of ice cream cones. Like, this was a lot of money. I mean, I'm just going to go out on a limb here and say, I don't think Ken always has the
best idea. Marv, maybe you should take a look at Ken's, like, budget for things. Also, why is Travis dressed like Santa Claus? Is it December? Is this their, like, nod to Christmas? Is this their Christmas episode cold? open? Listen, we don't know the answer to this question, but in my mind, the character of Travis is like, oh, we got to dress up. Okay, I have a Santa outfit. Yeah, I'm going to see kids.
Kids love Santa. And Ken's like, I'm going to dress like an ice cream dude. And Travis is like, oh, well, all I have is a Santa suit. I don't know. Because it looks like summer outside to me. Like, it looks warm. The kids are not wearing coats and scarves and stuff. It doesn't look like winter in Ohio. It looks like at best early autumn. Well, what it made me really, realize is that in season one of the paper, there was never a holiday episode. There was not a Halloween episode. There was not a Christmas. We have not seen this group celebrate a holiday. I would just put this out there, season two writers. I feel like a holiday episode would give lots of stuff to write in the paper. I know. And we personally, we loved getting to shoot them,
so I don't know. Maybe they're listening. Marrick could go report on the Christmas festival of lights. There you go. There it is. It writes itself. It writes itself. Well, just what you guys want. Writing pitches from us. Well, what's going to happen in this cold open, like we said, is the kids start to eat it.
They realize it's toilet paper. They get really angry. The parents get angry. They start throwing the toilet paper rolls at the truck. And then Ken and Travis have to peel out of there. And I just call BS on the parents. If I walk up to a truck that says by touching a cone, I wave any legal. claims or rights. I might be like, this is not the ice cream for us. Yeah. Also, if it's not
Christmas time and there's a man dressed as Santa inside of an ice cream truck, I'm going to steer my child in another direction. Yeah. Turn around. We did ask Dave Rogers about the scene, and this is what he said. He said one thing that was super tricky was the kids all wanted to throw the toilet paper cones as soon as we shot take one. But they only had a limited amount. So Dave needed these kids to wait before they could throw them. And I just can't imagine that because like you tell a kid they get to throw something. They're just going to go all out immediately. Well, we used to do stuff like that on the office. Like I remember there was a scene where a cake got destroyed, but we only had so many cakes. So we would shoot the top of it over and over and over again. And then we just shot the
destroy the cake part at the very end. Yeah. Dave said needless to say, cones would accidentally get thrown. So there'd always be one kid who couldn't resist. Well, now the episode begins, and we find out, mayor has been approved to go investigate if this, I guess, what is it? A farm is actually a cult. Yeah, it's a farm that's three hours south of Toledo, and she's pretty excited to get to the bottom of this. Also, her neighbor's son, I guess, is at the cult and missed his mom's birthday. so she's like, I'm going to investigate. She was supposed to go with Detrick, but when she goes to grab him to get on the road,
he says, I can't go with you. He's afraid he'll end up joining a cult. He had a dream about it the night before that he joined. So quickly, Ned comes out and is like, I'll go with you. And he's super excited about it. So now the two of them are going to take off on this adventure. Well, he loves buying his squash from this farm community at the farmer's market. Yeah.
He's like, I'd love to see where they grow it. Yeah. Up next is my favorite Esmeralda storyline in the whole first season so far. Really? Yes. Okay. I liked it more than her and Ken and Cahoots. Okay.
Yeah. I might vote for her and Ken and Cahoots, but I did like this one. I thought she shined. Oh, my God, Sabrina is so good. What we learn is, this first talking out is so funny. She found in the archives of the paper. an old picture of Barry when he was 30 and he was very handsome. He was very handsome.
Very handsome. Well, that image really stuck in Esmeralda's mind. And then I guess basically she has a sexual fantasy dream about Barry when he was in his 30s. But Esmeralda, of course, that's not how she like shares about it. She says Barry did something very inappropriate because he came into my dreams and he had his way with me. And she said, listen, if that happened once, fine. Okay, I was willing. There was a mutual attraction. But she's like, Barry is now coming to me every night. Okay. I have needs, maybe more than other people. But I mean, then I come into work and he pretends like nothing happened.
How dare he? As if Barry is going to know that she is having sexy time dreams about him. Lady, this happened to me. What? I had a sex dream about a coworker once. Is it Anyone I know? Yes. What? It was, yeah. And I couldn't look at him for three days. I couldn't look at him.
You know what? I think I know who it is. It was so weird. Are you going to say who it is? Can I guess? I'm having a memory. I'm having a memory. Shoot, I forget who it was.
But it wasn't who anyone would expect. Yes, I will only say this. I'm not going to say who it was because I don't want any clickbait articles about it. But it was during. my time on the office. It was while I sat at reception and this person sat in the bullpen. You could see everybody from reception. So I'm including everyone in the bullpen. Except not really the accounting nook. I could see the accounting nook if I wanted to. Okay. You're trying to whittle it down and I won't let you.
But it's not who all the clickbait people would want it to be. Correct. Correct. I'll just, it wasn't John, everybody. There. Yeah. But someone entered my dream, as happened to Sabrina, and we had hot, sexy time. Oh, my God, lady. And then I couldn't look at them for three days. I was so embarrassed. Well, I wonder if you had to do a curse. We'll get to it. Remove the curse. Angela, has that ever happened to you? Like, have you ever had a sex dream about a coworker or somebody who then you have to see? I haven't. Oh. I'm sorry. I haven't. I mean, every once in a while I'll watch a movie and then maybe like I have a dream about someone in the movie like that I found super attractive. Sure. That's so lame. I'm kind of lame. I think at work though, it's like, I don't know. I just always, I don't know. I don't know. I mean, I think it really surprised me because usually, you know, I just dream about someone like Brad Pitt giving me soup. Right. You know, like I dream that Ryan Gosling ran errands with me. And it was super hot.
You did? I didn't know that. He was like driving and I was in the passenger seat. And I was like running, I was like going through the list of places we needed to go. But I was so attracted to him and I was like, play it cool. Play it cool. You're just running errands. Oh, my God. I feel like our love languages are so clear. I know. Run errands with me or make me. me soup. Well, next up, we're going to get to the scene that you and I saw being filmed in person when we visited the set of the paper. It is this scene that begins Oscar's storyline, Oscar's delicious, wonderful storyline. He gets a comment. A little comment pops up on his computer. He's written a review of South Pacific, and someone has commented on it. Someone named
Go Mudheds 10. And they're insulting Oscar. They say, geez, how many more adverbs can you use? And they call him an ass hat. Yes, I love the term ass hat. I do as well. It makes me ass hat and dip shit. Always bring me joy. Those are your two faves?
Yeah. Adolola is going to have a talking head where she explains sort of the trend that's been happening. This troll will pounce on anyone that gets any tiny mistake wrong, but they use weirdly dated internet memes to insult everyone from probably circa 2012. Well, there was a runner in the extended peacock version where Travis, Detrick, and Adam read some of the outdated ways that go Mudhens Tin comment on things, and I just, it cracked me up. I wanted us to hear it.
Yeah. Adolola is going to have a talking head where she explains sort of the trend that's been happening. This troll will pounce on anyone that gets any tiny mistake wrong, but they use weirdly dated internet memes to insult everyone from probably circa 2012. Well, there was a runner in the extended peacock version where Travis, Detrick, and Adam read some of the outdated ways that go Mudheds Tin comment on things, and I just, it cracked me up. I wanted us to hear it.
Wow. Your third article about Brook Trout this week. It's a maze balls how you refuse to broaden your scope. Irmer Gerd. Dangling modifier alert. I don't understand. any of the epic fact check fail? This is funny.
Go-Wadden's 10 is funny. Yeah. This just made me laugh, like, amaze balls. Oh, my God. And, like, fail. It's as if, like, maybe me or you. Like, we're stuck in that time, too, I think, sometimes. We are.
Well, now Ned and Mera are going to get on the road. Ned goes to open up the door to Mair's car. She's going to drive, and a bunch of trash falls out. So much. I took a screen grab. There's all these take-out, containers, wrappers, water bottles. Like, it's all over the place. I was curious, you guys, is your car tidy? I want to do a poll in stories. Are you a mayor or are you like tidy
in your car? I feel like I'm between mayor and tidy. Like, things don't fall out of my car when you open the door. Like, mayor feels a lot more in the world of Michael Scott. Yeah. When Michael and Ryan are cleaning out his car, Blue Blast. Blue Blast. There's still. some night swept on the stick. And like the fish sandwiches containers. Sam, what about you? Are you mayor? Are you tidy? I'm obsessively neat and tidy with my heart. I get washed every week.
Oh, my goodness. All right. Matt. I've become very tidy. My wife, I don't know, she's pretty organized in general, but just treats the car like a total trash dump and like puts trash in pockets and little side holders. I'm like, why? So I clean it out now. But I wouldn't be like that normally. But it's a reaction to her. You know, so I'm always been pretty tidy with my car,
but there was a chapter of my life when the kids were little that I just had to like turn the other way. Yeah, I think that's it. There were those goldfish crackers everywhere in Cheerios and there'd be like some kind of sticky something on something. And I just was like, this is what this car is. This car is like a human people mover. It's a traveling high chair. Yes. That's what it was.
My wife will, like, take, we'll be at a party or something and, like, she'll have a paper plate and doesn't want to throw it out there. And, like, we'll take it and then, like, put it in our car. I'm like, you're taking trash into our car that doesn't have to be there. That's hilarious. I do have good friends where the wife is similar. And one time, impromptu, I asked her to give me a ride. We were leaving a thing at the school. And I was just like, oh, hey, could you give me a ride to my car?
I had to park far. And the look of just, like, sheer terror that came over her face. She was like, uh, I was like, it's just a few. Do you mind? And she was like, uh. And then when I walked up to her car, I was like, I think she saw my face of like, oh my God. I was like, you know what, I'll walk. It's fine.
It's fine. There was so much, you couldn't see the front seat. There was so much stuff. Wow. Wow. Okay. Well, did you notice Ned's Ziploc bag full of snacks for the car ride? I did.
It warmed my heart. It made me remember when we went on our work retreat up to Santa Barbara last year when we met Kendra. Yeah. You drove, Ang. Do you remember what I ate? It's all I ate. I was still during my treatment, and I would get really nauseous in the car, especially.
I mean, I was just spent a year nauseous, basically, but all I could eat was saltines. Yeah, I was going to say crackers, and they got everywhere. Everywhere. I just ate sleeves of saltines, the whole car ride. And I didn't understand how many little salting, cracker particles could like travel. I found them all over the place. I felt so bad. Like when we finally got home and dropped your car off, I was like, I apologize. Like, please. I'm so sorry. It's okay. It's okay. Well, we're back in the office now. Esmeralda's in the kitchen with Nicole and she's
explaining these sex dreams that she's having about him. It did crack me up. Nicole was like, wait, I'm confused. Are these like a nightmare? And Esmeralda's like, oh, He was wonderful. Okay, very surprising. I can't complain about that. But then she says, it's just now I think maybe he's an incubus. Like he's like a sexual demon. And Nicole's like, maybe you should talk to a professional about that. Well, I was curious what is an incubus. So I looked it up. First of all, it's a rock band. Oh, yeah, that I knew. Yep. But it is also a malevolent mythological demon. believed to sexually prey on women while they sleep, causing nightmares and sleep paralysis. Oh. Incidentally, you can also be haunted by a succubus, which is a female demon who comes to men in their dreams to seduce them and drain them of their energy.
And according to the National Library of Medicine, studies indicate that 11 to 12% of people in the general population have reported being visited by an incubus or a succubus. Come on. 11 to 12%. It's more common in students and psychiatric patients in that group of people. It has happened 41% of the time. Huh. Yeah.
But it's not considered a nightmare. It's an actual like haunting from a demon that enters your dreams and has sex with you. Huh. Well, we did get a letter. Not about that. Okay. This is very different, but I found it interesting. Trish from Chicago, Illinois, wrote in to say,
Hi there, long-time listener of office ladies, and I couldn't help but think of Angela Martin with this blouse that Esmeralda is wearing. Did you ladies see all of those buttons? Oh. Did you notice the blouse? Now that you say that. I know. I saw that comment, and I went and looked,
And it is like ye oldy blousey blouse with those tiny little, like, satin buttons that go all the way down and down the wrist as well. Yeah. But I can tell you who would not want an incubus, and that's Angela Martin. This is true. She would be like, get thee behind me, Satan. I feel like she would know what to do. She would. Well, now some really amazingly delicious, hilarious car driving scenes are going to start.
It's Ned and Mare in the car. I actually texted Chelsea and I said, I just want you to know we are going to be singing your praises because those driving scenes were amazing. I sent her the same text. Did you really? Yes. Well, the driving scenes start with Ned and Mear,
kind of wondering, would they be prey to a cult? Would they easily fall into one, right? And as they're talking, they go past like a meadow and there's sheep. And he's like, oh my gosh, that sheep looks like flossy. he had a sheep growing up. And then he tells mayor, but then, you know, it had to go live on this farm. And mayor is like, oh, my God, no, that sheep died.
They just tell you that. The animal's going to go live on a farm. Yeah, she's also like, wait, how did you have a sheep growing up? What are you, a Hungarian prince? That's what she says. And he's like, oh, I went to a petting zoo, and I fell in. love with this one sheep. And so then my parents bought it for me and let me bring it home, but then it wasn't housebroken. So then it had to go live on the farm. She's like, there's so many things that
you've just said that are so unrelatable. It's a very funny scene. And we got a fan question from Sheena P in Austin, Texas, who asked how much of the flossy conversation was improv. Well, I asked Chelsea, she said it was all pretty much scripted. She also said that her and Donal were just saying, because, you know, they're back shooting season two now. They were just reminiscing about season one and saying that this day of shooting these driving scenes was one of their most fun days to shoot. Well, I had some questions for Dave Rogers
you've just said that are so unrelatable. It's a very funny scene. And we got a fan question from Sheena P in Austin, Texas, who asked how much of the flossy conversation was improv. Well, I asked Chelsea, she said it was all pretty much scripted. She also said that her and Donal were just saying, because, you know, they're back shooting season two now. They were just reminiscing about season one and saying that this day of shooting these driving scenes was one of their most fun days to shoot. Well, I had some questions for Dave Rogers|||你刚才说的那番话太让人产生共鸣了。这是一个非常搞笑的场景。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州奥斯汀的希娜·P的粉丝提问，她问关于 flossy 的对话有多少是即兴发挥的。好吧，我问了切尔西，她说基本上全都是剧本写好的。她还说她和多纳尔当时只是在闲聊，因为，你知道的，他们现在正在回组拍第二季。他们只是在回忆第一季，并说拍摄这些开车镜头的这一天是他们拍得最开心的一天之一。好吧，我向戴夫·罗杰斯提出了一些问题|||
about these driving sequences. I wondered where they filmed them because it looked like real farm community. And we also had a question from Caitlin P. in Wakeman, Ohio, who said, was Mayor actually driving? And here's what Dave had to say about all of that. Dave said, okay, let me start by saying that the things we used to do in the office when we'd have the cast actually driving the cars
about these driving sequences. I wondered where they filmed them because it looked like real farm community. And we also had a question from Caitlin P. in Wakeman, Ohio, who said, was Mayor actually driving? And here's what Dave had to say about all of that. Dave said, okay, let me start by saying that the things we used to do in the office when we'd have the cast actually driving the cars|||关于这些开车戏份。我想知道他们在哪里拍摄的，因为看起来就像真实的农场社区。我们还收到了来自俄亥俄州韦克曼的凯特琳·P 的提问，她说，梅尔当时是真的在开车吗？以下是戴夫对这一切的看法。戴夫说，好吧，首先我要说的是，以前我们在《办公室》里让演员真正开车拍戏的那种做法|||
is now a thing of the past. Lady, that's probably a good idea. I mean, I can't believe I drove the car when Dwight ran me off the road. Yeah, I can't believe that Catherine and I were driving when I'm teaching Nellie to drive. And she's eating a salad. I mean, what are we thinking? Yeah. Craziness. Dave goes on to say, they actually don't let you. you free drive anymore, even if we have precision drivers on the road as background cars. We shot a lot of scenes on the office with cast driving, and I'm a fan of it as it looks real, because it is real, but I think all television shows have stopped allowing that because of safety reasons. So Mare was not really driving, but the car was also not on a trailer. Because that's the
is now a thing of the past. Lady, that's probably a good idea. I mean, I can't believe I drove the car when Dwight ran me off the road. Yeah, I can't believe that Catherine and I were driving when I'm teaching Nellie to drive. And she's eating a salad. I mean, what are we thinking? Yeah. Craziness. Dave goes on to say, they actually don't let you. you free drive anymore, even if we have precision drivers on the road as background cars. We shot a lot of scenes on the office with cast driving, and I'm a fan of it as it looks real, because it is real, but I think all television shows have stopped allowing that because of safety reasons. So Mare was not really driving, but the car was also not on a trailer. Because that's the|||现在已经成为过去了。天哪，这可能真是个好主意。我是说，我不敢相信当年德怀特把我逼出路面时真的是我在开车。对啊，我不敢相信我和凯瑟琳当时在开车，我还在教内莉开车，而她居然在吃沙拉。我是说，我们当时脑子里在想什么？对啊。太疯狂了。戴夫接着说，他们现在实际上不让你自由驾驶了，哪怕我们在路上有特技车手开着背景车辆。我们在《办公室》里拍过很多演员自己开车的镜头，我很喜欢这种方式，因为它看起来很真实，因为本来就是真的，但我认为所有的电视剧都出于安全原因停止允许这样做了。所以梅尔当时并不是真的在开车，但车子也没有放在拖车上。因为那是|||
other way we would do it. Sometimes we weren't really driving, but they would put the car onto the back of this big trailer and they would tow it. So it looks like you're driving, but you're just being towed. Yeah, but you're really out on the road. Yeah. But that was not the case here. No, Dave said because of the amount of driving scenes and the earlier sunset times that come with daylight savings, combined with a packed shooting schedule that included
other way we would do it. Sometimes we weren't really driving, but they would put the car onto the back of this big trailer and they would tow it. So it looks like you're driving, but you're just being towed. Yeah, but you're really out on the road. Yeah. But that was not the case here. No, Dave said because of the amount of driving scenes and the earlier sunset times that come with daylight savings, combined with a packed shooting schedule that included|||我们以前会用的另一种方法。有时我们确实不是在开车，但他们会把车放到这个大拖车的后面并进行拖拽。所以看起来你在开车，但你实际上只是被拖着走。对，但你确实是在公路上。对。但这次情况并非如此。不，戴夫说，由于驾驶戏份的数量，加上夏令时带来的更早的日落时间，再加上紧凑的拍摄日程，其中包括|||
shooting numerous other scenes on the same day, Dave described that there were these plates that literally wrapped around the car, the front sides and back, and there were also screens in the front of the windshield. And here's what that looks like, you guys. Jenna and I have both done this. Like, I did a driving scene for the television show better things. And when they have plates around the car, it had like scenery on these big, like, screens. Was that your experience, Jenna? Well, he's calling them plates because that's the industry term. But I think it's more accurate to say they're like giant green screens that surround the car. And then they project. the road onto it, the moving road,
shooting numerous other scenes on the same day, Dave described that there were these plates that literally wrapped around the car, the front sides and back, and there were also screens in the front of the windshield. And here's what that looks like, you guys. Jenna and I have both done this. Like, I did a driving scene for the television show better things. And when they have plates around the car, it had like scenery on these big, like, screens. Was that your experience, Jenna? Well, he's calling them plates because that's the industry term. But I think it's more accurate to say they're like giant green screens that surround the car. And then they project. the road onto it, the moving road,|||要在同一天拍摄许多其他场景，戴夫描述说，车周围实际上包裹着一些“板”，即前、侧和后方，挡风玻璃前面还有屏幕。大家来看看这到底是什么样子的。詹娜和我都经历过这种事。比如，我为电视剧《美好事物品》拍过开车戏。当车子周围有这些板时，这些巨大的屏幕上就会显示风景。詹娜，你也是这样的经历吗？嗯，他把它们叫做板（plate），因为那是行业术语。但我认为更准确的说法是，它们就像环绕汽车的巨大绿幕。然后他们会把……把道路投影到上面，也就是移动的道路，|||
onto these screens that surround the car. Yeah, there were like these huge squares on stands that surround the car. Yeah. And then they can put whatever they want on those big squares to show wherever you are. So my driving scene was in a city, there in the country. Yeah, I did this for that television show I did in London called Yumi and the Apocalypse. And it was crazy because like in this episode, there's, going to be a moment where like donal puts the window down, Ned puts the window down, and then like
onto these screens that surround the car. Yeah, there were like these huge squares on stands that surround the car. Yeah. And then they can put whatever they want on those big squares to show wherever you are. So my driving scene was in a city, there in the country. Yeah, I did this for that television show I did in London called Yumi and the Apocalypse. And it was crazy because like in this episode, there's, going to be a moment where like donal puts the window down, Ned puts the window down, and then like|||投射到环绕汽车的这些屏幕上。对，车周围有一些立在支架上的巨大正方形屏幕。对。然后他们可以在这些大正方形上放任何他们想要的东西来显示你所在的地方。所以我的开车戏是在城市里，而那是在乡村。对，我在伦敦拍的那部叫《世界末日与于美》的电视剧里也用过这个。太疯狂了，因为在这集中，会有这样一个时刻，比如多纳尔把车窗摇下来，内德把车窗摇下来，然后就像|||
all this air comes in. And so they have, it's like old-timey fans. And also like truly there's just some dudes in the back, just like rocking the car. Yeah, I did find it kind of surreal because I'd only ever done driving scenes on the office where we were actually on the road. So the things I looked out the window were real trees I was passing and stuff like that. And when I did my scene on better things. I'm in the back seat and we hit a bump. But it's kind of distracting because there's just like three men right outside. Yeah. Like kind of raising the car. David said while there are pros and cons to using this technique, ultimately, he felt like it looked pretty realistic and allowed them to have more shooting time. And that took away a lot of pressure for everyone. And I think you see them
all this air comes in. And so they have, it's like old-timey fans. And also like truly there's just some dudes in the back, just like rocking the car. Yeah, I did find it kind of surreal because I'd only ever done driving scenes on the office where we were actually on the road. So the things I looked out the window were real trees I was passing and stuff like that. And when I did my scene on better things. I'm in the back seat and we hit a bump. But it's kind of distracting because there's just like three men right outside. Yeah. Like kind of raising the car. David said while there are pros and cons to using this technique, ultimately, he felt like it looked pretty realistic and allowed them to have more shooting time. And that took away a lot of pressure for everyone. And I think you see them|||所有的风都灌进来了。所以他们准备了类似老式的电风扇。而且还真的有几个大汉在后面晃动车身。是的，我确实觉得这有点超现实，因为我在《办公室》里拍的开车戏全都是我们在真实道路上的。所以我窗外看到的是我经过的真实树木之类的东西。而我在拍《美好事物》的那场戏时。我坐在后座，车子颠簸了一下。但这有点让人分心，因为窗外正好有三个男人。对。就在那儿抬晃着车子。大卫说，虽然使用这种技术各有利弊，但总的来说，他觉得它看起来相当逼真，并且让他们有了更多的拍摄时间。这为每个人减轻了很大的压力。我想你也能看出他们|||
having fun. I think it really paid off. They tricked me. So I watched it and my question was the same. where did they do these driving scenes? And when we got this information from Dave, I went back and rewatched it. I can't tell at all. Same. I literally thought they took a road trip to like some part of Northern California
having fun. I think it really paid off. They tricked me. So I watched it and my question was the same. where did they do these driving scenes? And when we got this information from Dave, I went back and rewatched it. I can't tell at all. Same. I literally thought they took a road trip to like some part of Northern California|||玩得很开心。我觉得这真的很值得。他们把我给骗了。所以我看了之后，我的问题也是一样的：他们究竟是在哪里拍这些开车戏的？当我们从戴夫那里得到这个消息后，我又回去重新看了一遍。我完全看不出破绽。我也是。我真的以为他们是去北加州的某个地方自驾游了呢|||
where it's farming community. Same. Well, I had another question for Dave about how they shot these scenes, especially now knowing that they weren't really on the road. You know, Ange, my family is rewatching the office. It's my kids' first time seeing the show.
where is farming community. Same. Well, I had another question for Dave about how they shot these scenes, especially now knowing that they weren't really on the road. You know, Ange, my family is rewatching the office. It's my kids' first time seeing the show.|||那里的农场社区。我也是。好吧，关于他们是如何拍摄这些镜头的，我还有另一个问题想问戴夫，尤其是现在知道他们其实并不在公路上之后。你知道的，安吉，我的家人正在重温《办公室》。这是我孩子们第一次看这部剧。|||
It's been really fun. But something I'm noticing is how when we had driving scenes on the office, you know, we used the little lipstick cameras inside the car. Yeah. There is a real degrade in quality. Like if you see us in the office and then it cuts to people in the car, I didn't really notice it before.
It's been really fun. But something I'm noticing is how when we had driving scenes on the office, you know, we used the little lipstick cameras inside the car. Yeah. There is a real degrade in quality. Like if you see us in the office and then it cuts to people in the car, I didn't really notice it before.|||真的非常有趣。但我注意到的一点是，当我们在《办公室》里拍开车戏时，你知道的，我们在车里使用了小型口红摄像机。对。画质真的有明显的下降。比如，如果你看到我们在办公室里，然后镜头切换到车里的人，我以前真的没怎么注意到。|||
Like originally when I watched the show, but now in this rewatch, I'm really seeing it. And I asked Dave, like, this looks really clear. Like I'm not seeing that degrade in quality. Were you using lipstick cameras? Like, how did that work? And Dave said that the lipstick cameras that we used in the cars shooting the office, they did not have the same quality of resolution or lenses that our regular cameras had.
Like originally when I watched the show, but now in this rewatch, I'm really seeing it. And I asked Dave, like, this looks really clear. Like I'm not seeing that degrade in quality. Were you using lipstick cameras? Like, how did that work? And Dave said that the lipstick cameras that we used in the cars shooting the office, they did not have the same quality of resolution or lenses that our regular cameras had.|||就像我最初看这部剧时一样，但现在这次重温时，我真的看出来了。我问戴夫，比如，这个看起来真的很清晰。我没有看到画质下降。你们当时在用口红摄像机吗？那是怎么运作的？戴夫说，我们在《办公室》开车戏中使用的口红摄像机，其分辨率或镜头质量与我们的常规摄像机并不在同一个水平。|||
He said, but that was the style for documentaries back then. That was what happened on reality shows when you got in the car. And that they sort of saw that as part of the storytelling. They liked it. Yeah. They embraced it. He said, but now, you know, we're several years from the office ending. And he believes the documentary crew got some newer equipment.
He said, but that was the style for documentaries back then. That was what happened on reality shows when you got in the car. And that they sort of saw that as part of the storytelling. They liked it. Yeah. They embraced it. He said, but now, you know, we're several years from the office ending. And he believes the documentary crew got some newer equipment.|||他说，但那正是当年纪录片的风格。那是真人秀节目里一上车就会有的情况。他们把这视为讲故事的一部分。他们很喜欢。是的。他们欣然接受了这一点。他说，但现在，你知道的，距离《办公室》剧终已经过去了好几年。他相信纪录片摄制组换了一些更新的设备。|||
They still use lipstick cameras, but now lipstick cameras can get you a sharper image. And listen to this. They can be controlled remotely. You can zoom. You can pan. We couldn't do any of that stuff. Our lipstick cameras were fixed in one place. That's all you got.
They still use lipstick cameras, but now lipstick cameras can get you a sharper image. And listen to this. They can be controlled remotely. You can zoom. You can pan. We couldn't do any of that stuff. Our lipstick cameras were fixed in one place. That's all you got.|||他们现在还在使用口红摄像机，但如今的口红摄像机能为你带来更清晰的图像。而且听好了。它们可以远程控制。你可以变焦。你可以平移。我们当时可做不到这些。我们的口红摄像机是固定在一个地方的。你只能拿到那个固定的画面。|||
And you only saw what their lens saw. So he said they used three in the car. But they could pan. They could zoom. He said it was amazing. He said he positioned one as a wide shot. and then he did two that kind of were cross-angled. He wanted to be able to see the actors,
And you only saw what their lens saw. So he said they used three in the car. But they could pan. They could zoom. He said it was amazing. He said he positioned one as a wide shot. and then he did two that kind of were cross-angled. He wanted to be able to see the actors,|||你只能看到它们镜头里拍到的东西。所以他说他们在车里用了三个。但它们可以平移、可以变焦。他说这太棒了。他说他把其中一个定位为远景镜头。然后另外两个采用了某种交叉角度。他希望既能看到演员，|||
but he also wanted to see out the side windows. Well, you got me. I thought it was amazing. Amazing. Well, now we go back to the Toledo Truth Teller in the bullpen. Oscar is really spinning out over being called an ass hat. And he has a rant. Jenna and I both texted Oscar Nunez about how amazing he is in this rant.
but he also wanted to see out the side windows. Well, you got me. I thought it was amazing. Amazing. Well, now we go back to the Toledo Truth Teller in the bullpen. Oscar is really spinning out over being called an ass hat. And he has a rant. Jenna and I both texted Oscar Nunez about how amazing he is in this rant.|||但他也想拍到侧窗外面的景色。好吧，你把我折服了。我觉得这太神奇了。太神奇了。好了，现在我们回到开放式办公区的《托莱多真理报》。奥斯卡因为被骂作“混蛋”而彻底抓狂了。他发表了一番狂风暴雨般的抱怨。詹娜和我给奥斯卡·努涅斯发了短信，称赞他在这一段里的表演简直绝了。|||
I mean, eventually he's going to come on and we're going to talk to him all about it. But this was my chef's kiss moment of the episode. I think we should hear it. Oscar, do you have the order number for... As hat is just such an unforgivably stupid word. Unforgivably, another adverb. Okay, well, it's a vile thing to call someone.
I mean, eventually he's going to come on and we're going to talk to him all about it. But this was my chef's kiss moment of the episode. I think we should hear it. Oscar, do you have the order number for... As hat is just such an unforgivably stupid word. Unforgivably, another adverb. Okay, well, it's a vile thing to call someone.|||我是说，他最终会来节目，我们会和他好好聊聊这一切。但这绝对是我心目中这集的神级高光时刻。我觉得我们应该听听看。奥斯卡，你有……的订单号吗？“混蛋（Ass hat）”真是一个不可原谅的愚蠢词汇。“不可原谅地”，又是一个副词。好吧，骂别人这个词简直恶劣透顶。|||
But all I'm saying is how stupid it is. Because what? So in this scenario, what? I'm a little hat worn by an ass? An ass wears a hat? Or am I an ass? shaped hat. What?
But all I'm saying is how stupid it is. Because what? So in this scenario, what? I'm a little hat worn by an ass? An ass wears a hat? Or am I an ass? shaped hat. What?|||但我只想说它有多么愚蠢。因为什么？所以在这种情况下，什么？我是一只毛驴戴的小帽子？毛驴戴帽子？还是说我是一顶长得像毛驴形状的帽子？什么？|||
Do you see what I'm saying? Mm-hmm. You just, I want to find them. I want to find them and grab them and just explain to them how funny it is. The whole scenario, how amusing it is to me. That's all because you can't, but you can't because it's computers and it's internet. So you can't tell them because you can't find them because there's no way to- You could track down their IP address.
Do you see what I'm saying? Mm-hmm. You just, I want to find them. I want to find them and grab them and just explain to them how funny it is. The whole scenario, how amusing it is to me. That's all because you can't, but you can't because it's computers and it's internet. So you can't tell them because you can't find them because there's no way to- You could track down their IP address.|||你知道我在说什么吗？嗯哼。你只是……我想找到他们。我想找到他们，抓住他们，然后向他们解释这有多么搞笑。整个情境，对我来说有多么滑稽。这就是全部，因为你不能，但你不能，因为这是电脑，这是互联网。所以你不能告诉他们，因为你找不到他们，因为根本没办法——你可以查出他们的 IP 地址。|||
IP address? Yeah, it's traceable. I can track them. Oh, no. No. Oscar, look at me, dude. Revenge is a very dark road, and it can be surprisingly expensive. Okay, but if you do want to go down this road, you'd call IT, and the number is three, two, seven, one. Lady, I love the journey that Oscar goes on.
IP address? Yeah, it's traceable. I can track them. Oh, no. No. Oscar, look at me, dude. Revenge is a very dark road, and it can be surprisingly expensive. Okay, but if you do want to go down this road, you'd call IT, and the number is three, two, seven, one. Lady, I love the journey that Oscar goes on.|||IP 地址？对，这是可追踪的。我可以追踪他们。哦，不。不。奥斯卡，看着我，老兄。复仇是一条非常黑暗的道路，而且可能会贵得惊人。好吧，但如果你真的想走这条路，你应该打给IT部门，号码是三、二、七、一。天哪，我太喜欢奥斯卡经历的心路历程了。|||
He's angry, but then he's like, but it's funny. It's funny to me. Yeah. And then also a little bit that this dates all of us were of a certain generation that you're like, but you can't find it. It's computers. Yeah. There's no way you'll ever know. And they're like, actually, it's just you can drag down the IP address.
He's angry, but then he's like, but it's funny. It's funny to me. Yeah. And then also a little bit that this dates all of us were of a certain generation that you're like, but you can't find it. It's computers. Yeah. There's no way you'll ever know. And they're like, actually, it's just you can drag down the IP address.|||他很生气，但接着他又觉得：不过这挺搞笑的。我觉得挺搞笑的。对。还有一点就是，这暴露了我们所有人都是某个特定年代的人，你会觉得：“但你找不到啊，那是电脑。对啊。你永远都不可能知道的。”而别人则会说：“其实，你只要追踪IP地址就行了。”|||
We should mention that Oscar was nominated for a Critics Choice Award for the paper for best supporting actor in a comedy. And this is why, guys, this is it right here. Watch this scene. He does this very funny thing, too, where he does like a little tiny hat, like on his head. He's like, am I an ass and wears a hat? Like, it's great. Oscar's just brilliant. Well, why don't we take a break?
We should mention that Oscar was nominated for a Critics Choice Award for the paper for best supporting actor in a comedy. And this is why, guys, this is it right here. Watch this scene. He does this very funny thing, too, where he does like a little tiny hat, like on his head. He's like, am I an ass and wears a hat? Like, it's great. Oscar's just brilliant. Well, why don't we take a break?|||我们应该提一下，奥斯卡凭借《纸牌屋》获得了评论家选择奖喜剧类最佳男配角的提名。这就是原因所在，伙计们，就是这个。看这个场景。他还做了一个非常搞笑的动作，把一顶极小的帽子放在头顶上。他说：“难道我是一只戴帽子的驴吗？”太棒了。奥斯卡简直是个天才。好了，我们为什么不休息一下呢？|||
And when we come back, there is a spider in Mayer's car. I'm sorry, I'm laughing about it. I know. Because it's so good, I watched this scene so many times. We need to break it down. We'll be back. We are back, and it's time for... Around the town.
And when we come back, there is a spider in Mayer's car. I'm sorry, I'm laughing about it. I know. Because it's so good, I watched this scene so many times. We need to break it down. We'll be back. We are back, and it's time for... Around the town.|||等我们回来的时候，梅尔的车里出现了一只蜘蛛。对不起，我一想到这儿就笑。我知道。因为实在太精彩了，这个场景我看了好多次。我们得好好剖析一下。我们马上回来。我们回来了，现在是……“城市周遭”环节。|||
Our first one is from Sarah T in Burlington, Wisconsin. Sarah wrote in and said, Every winter, my town puts an old car on the ice of the lake downtown. There is a contest for whoever can guess the day it falls through the ice. It just recently made its yearly appearance. Sam. So many questions. I have so many questions.
Our first one is from Sarah T in Burlington, Wisconsin. Sarah wrote in and said, Every winter, my town puts an old car on the ice of the lake downtown. There is a contest for whoever can guess the day it falls through the ice. It just recently made its yearly appearance. Sam. So many questions. I have so many questions.|||第一个来自威斯康星州伯灵顿的萨拉·T。萨拉来信写道：每年冬天，我们镇都会把一辆旧车放到市中心湖泊的冰面上。有一个竞猜比赛，看谁能猜出它在哪一天会掉进冰窟窿里。它最近刚刚完成了它一年一度的亮相。萨拉。我有太多的问题了。我有无数个问题。|||
I actually Googled this after I read it. This is a whole thing. Yeah, this is right where I grew up. I remember this, yeah. They put all kinds of things on the ice. Yeah, they do. Refrigerators, all sorts of things. I saw one where they made a giant kind of like, look.
I actually Googled this after I read it. This is a whole thing. Yeah, this is right where I grew up. I remember this, yeah. They put all kinds of things on the ice. Yeah, they do. Refrigerators, and all sorts of things. I saw one where they made a giant kind of like, look.|||我读完之后实际上还去谷歌搜索了一下。这居然是一项大活动。对，这就是我长大的地方。我记得这个，对。他们会在冰面上放各种各样的东西。对，他们会的。电冰箱，还有各种各样的东西。我看到过一个，他们做一个巨大的，类似于……看。|||
look like a paper-machet statue of a person, like to see when he slowly sank in. When do they get the stuff out? I don't know that they ever do. No. They have to drag it out. There's just cars and refrigerators at the bottom of this lake. Look, I'm going to assume so. Oh, no.
look like a paper-machet statue of a person, like to see when he slowly sank in. When do they get the stuff out? I don't know that they ever do. No. They have to drag it out. There's just cars and refrigerators at the bottom of this lake. Look, I'm going to assume so. Oh, no.|||看起来像是用纸浆塑形做的人形雕像，想看看它什么时候慢慢沉下去。他们什么时候把这些东西弄出来？我不知道他们到底会不会弄出来。不。他们必须把它们拖捞出来。这个湖底全都是汽车和冰箱。听着，我只能这么假设了。哦，不。|||
I hope they drag them out. Who's going to drag them out? Whose responsibility is that? I don't know. Also, the contest, what do you win? Just bragging rights? I'm going to assume meat or beer or cheese. It's Burlington, Wisconsin.
I hope they drag them out. Who's going to drag them out? Whose responsibility is that? I don't know. Also, the contest, what do you win? Just bragging rights? I'm going to assume meat or beer or cheese. It's Burlington, Wisconsin.|||我希望他们把它们捞出来。谁会去捞它们？那是谁的责任？我不知道。还有，这个比赛，你能赢得什么？只是吹牛的资本吗？我猜是肉、啤酒或者奶酪。这可是威斯康星州的伯灵顿。|||
Sarah, we have questions. Sarah, we have questions. I also know winter really drags on up there, and you kind of need to make some entertainment for yourself. Oh, yeah, I'm on board with this. Next up is Kristen A from Shenandoah, Iowa, who said, I run a small dealership in Southwest Iowa. We were just named the Iowa nomination for the National Independent Quality Dealer Award.
Sarah, we have questions. Sarah, we have questions. I also know winter really drags on up there, and you kind of need to make some entertainment for yourself. Oh, yeah, I'm on board with this. Next up is Kristen A from Shenandoah, Iowa, who said, I run a small dealership in Southwest Iowa. We were just named the Iowa nomination for the National Independent Quality Dealer Award.|||萨拉，我们有问题。萨拉，我们有问题。我也知道那里的冬天真的很漫长难熬，你确实得给自己找点乐子。哦，对，我太赞同这个了。接下来是来自艾奥瓦州谢南多厄的克里斯滕·A，她说：我在艾奥瓦州西南部经营一家小型汽车经销店。我们刚刚获得了国家独立优质经销商奖的艾奥瓦州提名。|||
Hey, congratulations. Kristen? The winner will be announced in June at the National Convention. It's based on industry involvement, business operations, and community involvement. It's huge for our town and huge for women thriving in a male-dominated industry. So wish us luck. Good luck. Good luck, Kristen. Next up we have Beth S from Columbia, Maryland. Beth says, Proud Mom, reporting from Howard County, Maryland, High school actor and avid the office fan, Luke, is now assistant stage manager of this spring's production of Cinderella the musical. After over 10 years of acting in youth theater programs, Luke has decided to explore other aspects of theater and begin training to be stage manager acting as assistant stage manager this season. He hopes to continue in this role as he continues high school with some acting should the perfect role come around.
Hey, congratulations. Kristen? The winner will be announced in June at the National Convention. It's based on industry involvement, business operations, and community involvement. It's huge for our town and huge for women thriving in a male-dominated industry. So wish us luck. Good luck. Good luck, Kristen. Next up we have Beth S from Columbia, Maryland. Beth says, Proud Mom, reporting from Howard County, Maryland, High school actor and avid the office fan, Luke, is now assistant stage manager of this spring's production of Cinderella the musical. After over 10 years of acting in youth theater programs, Luke has decided to explore other aspects of theater and begin training to be stage manager acting as assistant stage manager this season. He hopes to continue in this role as he continues high school with some acting should the perfect role come around.|||嘿，恭喜。克里斯滕？获胜者将于六月份在全国代表大会上公布。这是根据行业参与度、业务运营和社区参与度来评选的。这对我们镇来说是一件大事，对于在男性主导的行业中蓬勃发展的女性来说也是一件大事。所以祝我们好运吧。祝你好运。祝你好运，克里斯滕。接下来是来自马里兰州哥伦比亚的贝丝·S。贝丝说：“骄傲的妈妈”从马里兰州霍华德县发来报道，高中演员兼《办公室》的狂热粉丝卢克，现在是今年春季音乐剧《灰姑娘》制作组的助理舞台经理。在青年戏剧项目中表演了十多年后，卢克决定探索戏剧的其他方面，并开始接受舞台经理的培训，本赛季担任助理舞台经理。他希望在继续读高中的同时继续担任这一角色，如果有合适的角色出现，也会进行一些表演。|||
Luke, thank you so much for exploring stage management. It is such an important part of the theater experience. I mean, you're the Kelly Cantley of the show. You're the first AD. You keep it going. You keep the schedule, the props. You call the show. You call the show.
Luke, thank you so much for exploring stage management. It is such an important part of the theater experience. I mean, you're the Kelly Cantley of the show. You're the first AD. You keep it going. You keep the schedule, the props. You call the show. You call the show.|||卢克，非常感谢你探索舞台管理。这是戏剧体验中极其重要的一部分。我的意思是，你就是剧组里的凯利·坎特利。你就是第一副导演。你维持着一切的运转。你掌管着日程、道具。你掌握着演出调度。你掌握着演出调度。|||
None of it happens without you. Without a great stage management team. So I love it. And also keep performing, Luke. Yeah. All right. Our last Around the Town from Jenny L. in Big Piney, Wyoming.
None of it happens without you. Without a great stage management team. So I love it. And also keep performing, Luke. Yeah. All right. Our last Around the Town from Jenny L. in Big Piney, Wyoming.|||没有你，这一切都不会发生。没有一个伟大的舞台管理团队，这一切都不可能实现。所以我太喜欢了。另外，卢克，继续表演哦。好的。我们最后一个“城市周遭”来自怀俄明州大派妮的珍妮·L。|||
Miss Camilla R, a senior at Big Piney High School, became the first female and only second wrestler in school history to win the statewide wrestling tournament Ron Thon. In Wyoming, this means you are the best wrestler in your weight class in the whole state because they do not break into school-sized classifications. Congratulations, Camia! Yeah.
Miss Camilla R, a senior at Big Piney High School, became the first female and only second wrestler in school history to win the statewide wrestling tournament Ron Thon. In Wyoming, this means you are the best wrestler in your weight class in the whole state because they do not break into school-sized classifications. Congratulations, Camia! Yeah.|||大派妮高中的高三学生卡米拉·R 小姐，成为了该校历史上第一位、也是仅有的第二位赢得全州摔跤锦标赛“罗恩·汤恩”冠军的女摔跤手。在怀俄明州，这意味着你是全州同量级中最优秀的摔跤手，因为他们不按学校规模进行组别划分。恭喜卡米拉！太棒了。|||
What a huge accomplishment. Way to go. I loved hearing about these young people who are out there doing what they love and just crushing it. Thank you so much for writing in and sending you around the towns. It just makes me so happy. And I think of my grandmother every time. Keep them coming. You can find the folder for your submission on officeladys.com.
What a huge accomplishment. Way to go. I loved hearing about these young people who are out there doing what they love and just crushing it. Thank you so much for writing in and sending you around the towns. It just makes me so happy. And I think of my grandmother every time. Keep them coming. You can find the folder for your submission on officeladys.com.|||多么巨大的成就啊。干得漂亮。我很高兴听到这些年轻人走出去做他们热爱的事情并且大获成功。非常感谢你们来信分享你们的“城市周遭”。这真的让我太开心了。每次我都忍不住想起我的奶奶。请继续发来投稿吧。你可以在 officeladys.com 上找到用于提交投稿的文件夹。|||
All right. Let's get back to this paper breakdown, Angela. Like we said, we're going to be back in the car with Mayor and Ned. Yeah. It starts with Mayor eating a bag of chip. which she then just throws over her shoulder into the backseat. And then Mayor gets a call from a writer from Cleveland Today magazine who was very impressed by her article on the sewer clog.
All right. Let's get back to this paper breakdown, Angela. Like we said, we're going to be back in the car with Mayor and Ned. Yeah. It starts with Mayor eating a bag of chip. which she then just throws over her shoulder into the backseat. And then Mayor gets a call from a writer from Cleveland Today magazine who was very impressed by her article on the sewer clog.|||好了。安吉拉，让我们回到这份报纸的剖析上来。就像我们说的，我们将再次和梅尔与内德一起坐在车里。对。故事开始于梅尔正在吃一包薯片。然后她随手把包装袋往肩膀后一扔，扔到了后座上。接着梅尔接到了《克利夫兰今日》杂志一位作家的电话，这位作家对她关于下水道堵塞的文章印象深刻。|||
And while Mayor is talking to this writer, she spies out of the corner of her eye a pretty big black spider crawling alongside the window next to Ned. Yeah, so she kind of motioned, she's like, could you get rid of that spider? And he's like, oh, he is completely unnerved by the spider. He does so many hijinks trying to basically get this spider into a cup. He's got like a piece of paper.
And while Mayor is talking to this writer, she spies out of the corner of the eye a pretty big black spider crawling alongside the window next to Ned. Yeah, so she kind of motioned, she's like, could you get rid of that spider? And he's like, oh, he is completely unnerved by the spider. He does so many hijinks trying to basically get this spider into a cup. He's got like a piece of paper.|||正当梅尔与这位作家交谈时，她用眼角余光瞥见一只挺大的黑蜘蛛正沿着内德身旁的窗户爬行。对，于是她做了一个手势，意思是：你能把那只蜘蛛弄走吗？而他却表现得——噢，他被这只蜘蛛彻底吓坏了。他手忙脚乱地搞出了各种花样，试图把这只蜘蛛弄进一个杯子里。他拿了一张纸。|||
He's got an old paper cup. He's trying to shove it in. And Mare's like, just smush it. Just smush it. And Ned's like, I have a system. And it's humane. He's going to try to get the spider out the window. And he tries to throw it out the window.
He's got an old paper cup. He's trying to shove it in. And Mare's like, just smush it. Just smush it. And Ned's like, I have a system. And it's humane. He's going to try to get the spider out the window. And he tries to throw it out the window.|||他拿了一个旧纸杯。他试图把它塞进去。而梅尔则说：“直接捏死它。直接捏死它。”内德却说：“我有我的一套系统。而且这很有人情味。”他试图把蜘蛛弄到窗户外面去。于是他试图把它扔出窗外。|||
It does that thing where like the web sort of connects to the cup and then it swings in his face. And it blows back into the car. car, but he can't find it. Is it on him somewhere? He panics. He, like, makes up this noise, which is hilarious. He's like, ah, it's all the while. Mare is trying to have this very serious conversation with this writer, and it is hilarious. We got a question from Christine K in Dublin, Ireland, who said, hey, ladies, I'd love to know everything about the spider in the car scene. Was the spider CGI? How was it choreographed? How much was improv? It just cracks me up every single time I watch it. The physical comedy is brilliant, Mr. Bean level. Well, we asked Dave,
It does that thing where like the web sort of connects to the cup and then it swings in his face. And it blows back into the car. car, but he can't find it. Is it on him somewhere? He panics. He, like, makes up this noise, which is hilarious. He's like, ah, it's all the while. Mare is trying to have this very serious conversation with this writer, and it is hilarious. We got a question from Christine K in Dublin, Ireland, who said, hey, ladies, I'd love to know everything about the spider in the car scene. Was the spider CGI? How was the choreographed? How much was improv? It just cracks me up every single time I watch it. The physical comedy is brilliant, Mr. Bean level. Well, we asked Dave,|||结果出现了那种情况：蜘蛛网好像连在了杯子上，然后它荡到了他的脸上。接着它被吹回了车里。车里，但他找不到了。它是在他身上的某个地方吗？他惊慌失措。他发出了一种滑稽的叫声。他喊道：“啊——”与此同时。梅尔正努力与这位作家进行非常严肃的对话，这场景实在太搞笑了。我们收到了来自爱尔兰都柏林的克里斯蒂娜·K 的提问，她说：嘿，女士们，我很想知道关于车里那场蜘蛛戏的所有细节。那只蜘蛛是 CGI 特效吗？它是怎么编排的？有多少是即兴发挥的？每次我看这一段都笑得前仰后合。肢体喜剧简直绝了，达到了憨豆先生的级别。好吧，我们问了戴夫，|||
Dave said the spider was CGI. They rehearsed and guided the actors on exactly where the spider would be and what it would be doing. Dave said Donal just really sold it. He did. He sold getting hit in the face with it, trying to get it off his body. He said the visual effects team did an amazing job, making it all feel real. Dave said at one point in pre-production, they did talk about having a real spider. They even talked about having a real spider walk across one of the lipstick cameras, but Dave said he thought it was kind of unnecessary. He was afraid that it wouldn't register as clearly. I mean, this is just reminding me of how when we did that fruit fly scene in the break room of the office, it was real. They brought in a fruit fly wrangler. There's so many things I'm noticing that we
Dave said the spider was CGI. They rehearsed and guided the actors on exactly where the spider would be and what it would be doing. Dave said Donal just really sold it. He did. He sold getting hit in the face with it, trying to get it off his body. He said the visual effects team did an amazing job, making it all feel real. Dave said at one point in pre-production, they did talk about having a real spider. They even talked about having a real spider walk across one of the lipstick cameras, but Dave said he thought it was kind of unnecessary. He was afraid that it wouldn't register as clearly. I mean, this is just reminding me of how when we did that fruit fly scene in the break room of the office, it was real. They brought in a fruit fly wrangler. There's so many things I'm noticing that we|||戴夫说蜘蛛是电脑特效（CGI）。他们排练并指导了演员，明确了蜘蛛的具体位置以及它要做什么。戴夫说多纳尔演得太逼真了。确实如此。他把被蜘蛛打在脸上、试图把它从身上弄下来的反应演得淋漓尽致。他说视觉效果团队做得非常棒，让这一切感觉都像真的一样。戴夫说，在前期制作的某个阶段，他们确实讨论过使用真正的蜘蛛。他们甚至讨论过让真正的蜘蛛从其中一个口红摄像机前爬过去，但戴夫说他觉得这有点多此一举。他担心它拍出来的清晰度不够高。我是说，这让我想起了当年我们在《办公室》的休息室里拍那场果蝇戏时，那是真的。他们请来了一位果蝇驯养师。我注意到有太多事情是我们|||
did on the office. We were really driving. We brought actual fruit flies in. And now they can do it with all of this technology. I think about what Greg said when he was on our episode breaking down the booze cruise, that they went to such effort to have this boat go out into the open ocean at night so you could see that we were on the ocean at night. And he said, it just looked black. Yeah, he said we could have very easily been on a sound stage. And probably if we were on a soundstage. And probably if we were on a soundstage, they could have made us look more like we were out at sea. Because you're right. I remember that. He said we pointed the cameras out and you could see nothing. It was just night. And then they wouldn't have lost four actors out to see.
did on the office. We were really driving. We brought actual fruit flies in. And now they can do it with all of this technology. I think about what Greg said when he was on our episode breaking down the booze cruise, that they went to such effort to have this boat go out into the open ocean at night so you could see that we were on the ocean at night. And he said, it just looked black. Yeah, he said we could have very easily been on a sound stage. And probably if we were on a soundstage. And probably if we were on a soundstage, they could have made us look more like we were out at sea. Because you're right. I remember that. He said we pointed the cameras out and you could see nothing. It was just night. And then they wouldn't have lost four actors out to see.|||在《办公室》里做过的。我们当时是真的在开车。我们带了真正的果蝇进去。而现在他们利用所有这些技术就能做到这一点。我想起格雷格在我们剖析“酒水游轮”那一集节目中所说的话，他们为了让这艘船在夜里开进公海而付出了巨大的努力，这样你就能看出我们当时是在夜海之中。而他说，结果拍出来看起来只是一片漆黑。是的，他说我们完全可以就在摄影棚里拍。而且如果我们在摄影棚里拍的话。而且如果我们在摄影棚里拍的话，他们本可以让我们看起来更像是置身于大海上。因为你说得对。我记得这件事。他说我们把镜头朝外拍，却什么也看不见。只有一片黑夜。那样的话，他们也就不会把四个演员弄丢到海里去了。|||
I mean, they were trying to get to shore. But then we wouldn't have had all these fun stories. We wouldn't have all the stories. And people wouldn't have actually really gotten nauseous, which is what happened. Yes. Well, I couldn't help but think, this is so random. But I was watching the scene and I'm cracking up about the spider and sort of like the two types of people. Like Marr's like, just smush it. And he's like, no, I want to help it get back to nature. Lady, Josh and I went to look at tile. Okay, we have a leak in our son's bathroom.
I mean, they were trying to get to shore. But then we wouldn't have had all these fun stories. We wouldn't have all the stories. And people wouldn't have actually really gotten nauseous, which is what happened. Yes. Well, I couldn't help but think, this is so random. But I was watching the scene and I'm cracking up about the spider and sort of like the two types of people. Like Marr's like, just smush it. And he's like, no, I want to help it get back to nature. Lady, Josh and I went to look at tile. Okay, we have a leak in our son's bathroom.|||我是说，他们当时正试图划回岸边。但那样的话，我们就不会有所有这些有趣的故事了。我们就不会有这些故事了。人们也不会真的恶心呕吐了，而这确实发生了。是的。嗯，我不禁在想，这太随性了。但我看着这个场景，为蜘蛛的事情笑得不行，同时也想到了两种不同类型的人。就像梅尔说“直接把它捏死”，而他说“不，我想帮它回归自然”。天哪，乔什和我去挑选瓷砖。好吧，我们儿子的浴室漏水了。|||
Yeah. In the shower, they're going to have to bust open the tile. Anyway, we're going to have to replace the tile. So we go to this tile store together. We open the door and walk in. And there's like this kind of. little lobby way, but only in the way that a tile store would do a lobby, which means that the lobby itself, the tile features all kinds of different tile.
Yeah. In the shower, they're going to have to bust open the tile. Anyway, we're going to have to replace the tile. So we go to this tile store together. We open the door and walk in. And there's like this kind of. little lobby way, but only in the way that a tile store would do a lobby, which means that the lobby itself, the tile features all kinds of different tile.|||对。淋浴间的瓷砖得被砸开。总之，我们必须更换瓷砖。于是我们一起去了这家瓷砖店。我们推开门走进去。里面有一个……小小的门厅通道，但只有瓷砖店才会把门厅弄成的那种风格，这意味着门厅本身、所有的瓷砖特色都展示着各种各样不同的瓷砖。|||
Yeah, I know what you're talking about. So you walk in and there was a woman kind of sitting behind a computer and she's like, do you guys have an appointment? And I was like, we do. And we had just stepped in. We're like two steps into this tile store. And then this other woman walks past us in front of us. She's got a clipboard.
Yeah, I know what you're talking about. So you walk in and there was a woman kind of sitting behind a computer and she's like, do you guys have an appointment? And I was like, we do. And we had just stepped in. We're like two steps into this tile store. And then this other woman walks past us in front of us. She's got a clipboard.|||对，我知道你在说什么。所以你走进去，有一个女人坐在电脑后面，她问：“你们有预约吗？”我说：“有的。”而我们才刚走进来。我们刚进这家瓷砖店两步。然后另一个女人从我们身前走过。她手里拿着一个夹板。|||
She works there. and all of us at the same time, four strangers, clock, this huge spider crawling across their tile lobby. And this woman doesn't even skip a step. She just strolls past us and boom, steps on it, smushes it. It's a big spider. It's a big smush. And then she just keeps on going, leaves the spider carcass. And me and Josh are like, uh,
She works there. and all of us at the same time, four strangers, clock, this huge spider crawling across their tile lobby. And this woman doesn't even skip a step. She just strolls past us and boom, steps on it, smushes it. It's a big spider. It's a big smush. And then she just keeps on going, leaves the spider carcass. And me and Josh are like, uh,|||她是那里的员工。我们所有人——四个素不相识的陌生人，同时注意到这只巨大的蜘蛛正在他们铺满瓷砖的门厅里爬行。而这个女人脚步都没有停顿一下。她径直从我们身边走过，轰的一声踩了上去，把它捏碎了。那是一只大蜘蛛。碎得很彻底。然后她就继续往前走，留下了蜘蛛的尸体。我和乔什当时就觉得，呃……|||
Wait, is anyone going to, do I, what do we do here? Do we tidy up this thing? Do we just go about our day? It was so odd. It was so like just a weird moment between four strangers. I mean, I would find that unnerving. I'm a scoop it into the cup person. I'm a scoop it into the cup person too.
Wait, is anyone going to, do I, what do we do here? Do we tidy up this thing? Do we just go about our day? It was so odd. It was so like just a weird moment between four strangers. I mean, I would find that unnerving. I'm a scoop it into the cup person. I'm a scoop it into the cup person too.|||等等，有人会……是我吗，我们在这里该怎么办？我们要清理这个东西吗？还是我们就当作没事发生继续过我们的一天？这太奇怪了。四个陌生人之间发生了如此诡异的一幕。我是说，我会觉得那让人很不安心。我是那种会把它铲进杯子里的人。我也是那种会把它铲进杯子里的人。|||
I'm like, let's try to, like, I was playing tennis the other day. There was a bee on the tennis court. I'm like, wait, wait, wait. I went and got a stick. I tried to get the bee to crawl on the stick. and then I took the bee on the stick over to the bushes. I mean, listen, we need to protect our bees and spiders. They're actually really important.
I'm like, let's try to, like, I was playing tennis the other day. There was a bee on the tennis court. I'm like, wait, wait, wait. I went and got a stick. I tried to get the bee to crawl on the stick. and then I took the bee on the stick over to the bushes. I mean, listen, we need to protect our bees and spiders. They're actually really important.|||我心想，让我们试着……就像我前几天打网球一样。网球场上有一只蜜蜂。我心想：等等，等等，等等。我去拿了一根树枝。我试着让蜜蜂爬到树枝上。然后我拿着带着蜜蜂的树枝把它送到了灌木丛边。我是说，听着，我们需要保护我们的蜜蜂和蜘蛛。它们其实非常重要。|||
You know, they eat mosquitoes. Well, thankfully, Ned did not squish this spider because we would have missed out on this hilarious scene. Yeah. Well, now, I think maybe one of my favorite moments, I mean, there's so many in this episode. Next to the whole spider storyline, we're back with Esmeralda.
You know, they eat mosquitoes. Well, thankfully, Ned did not squish this spider because we would have missed out on this hilarious scene. Yeah. Well, now, I think maybe one of my favorite moments, I mean, there's so many in this episode. Next to the whole spider storyline, we're back with Esmeralda.|||你知道的，它们吃蚊子。好吧，谢天谢地，内德没有捏死这只蜘蛛，否则我们就错失了这个搞笑的场景了。对。好吧，现在，我觉得这或许是我最喜欢的时刻之一——我是说这一集里这样的时刻太多了。除了整条蜘蛛的故事线之外，我们又回到了埃斯梅拉达这里。|||
She is going to give Barry a gift, a quote-unquote gift she found in the mailroom. really, this is her taking the advice of her psychic on how to break the curse. She has a talking head about all the steps she's taking to break this curse, and I really want us to hear it. I'm trying to be rational and practical about this very situation. Of course, I sprinkle salt on my doorstep and on my windowsills. That did nothing. Now, my psychic told me that there is another method that is scientifically proven, that is
She is going to give Barry a gift, a quote-unquote gift she found in the mailroom. really, this is her taking the advice of her psychic on how to break the curse. She has a talking head about all the steps she's taking to break this curse, and I really want us to hear it. I'm trying to be rational and practical about this very situation. Of course, I sprinkle salt on my doorstep and on my windowsills. That did nothing. Now, my psychic told me that there is another method that is scientifically proven, that is|||她要送给巴里一份礼物，一个她在收发室里找到的“所谓的”礼物。实际上，这是她听从了灵媒关于如何打破诅咒的建议。她有一段独白，讲述了她为打破这个诅咒而采取的所有步骤，我真的很想让我们大家听听看。我正试图以理性务实的方式来对待眼前的这种情况。当然，我在家门口和窗台上都撒了盐。那一点用都没有。现在，我的灵媒告诉我，还有另一种经过科学证明的方法，那就是|||
going to break the incubus. Oh, wow, that looks nice. I think you should wear it for seven days and seven nights without showering and then bury it under a red rock with the full moon. So, yeah, she's given Barry this necklace and it's got garlic in it. He just smells it. It's like, and he tosses it in the trash. Esmeralda is so pissed. She walks past and she like throws a chair in the floor. She's like, damn it, Barry. This did make me be a little. lady that Googles. What'd you Google? Different ways to break a curse. Oh, what'd you find? Well, have you ever heard of any of these? I'm just going to throw out a few. The uncrossing bath. You take a bath with ingredients meant to uncross you, such as salt, rue, sage, I don't know,
going to break the incubus. Oh, wow, that looks nice. I think you should wear it for seven days and seven nights without showering and then bury it under a red rock with the full moon. So, yeah, she's given Barry this necklace and it's got garlic in it. He just smells it. It's like, and he tosses it in the trash. Esmeralda is so pissed. She walks past and she like throws a chair in the floor. She's like, damn it, Barry. This did make me be a little. lady that Googles. What'd you Google? Different ways to break a curse. Oh, what's you find? Well, have you ever heard of any of these? I'm just going to throw out a few. The uncrossing bath. You take a bath with ingredients meant to uncross you, such as salt, rue, sage, I don't know,|||彻底打破梦魇的纠缠。哦，哇，这个看起来不错。我觉得你应该连续七天七夜戴着它洗澡也不要摘下来，然后在满月之夜把它埋在一块红色的石头下面。所以，是的，她把这个里面装了大蒜的项链送给了巴里。他闻了一下。然后就，直接把它扔进了垃圾桶。埃斯梅拉达气坏了。她走过去，把一把椅子扔在地上。她气冲冲地说：“该死的，巴里。”这确实让我成了一个会去谷歌搜索的女士。你谷歌了什么？破解诅咒的不同方法。哦，你找到了什么？好吧，你听说过其中的任何一种吗？我随便列举几个。解除厄咒浴。你用旨在消除霉运的成分洗澡，比如盐、芸香、鼠尾草，我不知道，|||
egg cleanse. You roll a raw egg over your body to absorb the negative energy, but then you have to dispose of it far from your home. Hmm. Salt protection, as Morelta mentions this. You put salt under your dormats in the corners, put it around your house to remove negative influences. Then there's protective herbs. Then there's a thing with a broom. Have you heard of this lady?
egg cleanse. You roll a raw egg over your body to absorb the negative energy, but then you have to dispose of it far from your home. Hmm. Salt protection, as Morelta mentions this. You put salt under your dormats in the corners, put it around your house to remove negative influences. Then there's protective herbs. Then there's a thing with a broom. Have you heard of this lady?|||鸡蛋净化法。你用生鸡蛋在身上滚动以吸收负能量，但之后你必须把它扔到远离你家的地方。嗯。盐保护法，埃斯梅拉达提到了这个。你把盐放在门垫下的角落里，撒在房子四周以消除负面影响。然后是护身草药。然后还有关于扫帚的法子。你听说过这个吗，女士？|||
You placed a broom upside down behind the door to ward off negative visitors. I mean, it goes on and on. There was a lot. Well, I also Googled. Oh. I was a lady who Googled. What did you Google? Well, I googled how to rid yourself of an incubus.
You placed a broom upside down behind the door to ward off negative visitors. I mean, it goes on and on. There was a lot. Well, I also Googled. Oh. I was a lady who Googled. What did you Google? Well, I googled how to rid yourself of an incubus.|||你把扫帚倒着放在门后以驱赶不速之客。我是说，这类的法子多得数不清。真的有很多。好吧，我也谷歌了。哦。我成了一个爱谷歌搜索的女士。你谷歌了什么？好吧，我谷歌了如何摆脱梦魇（魅魔）。|||
Well, that's very specific. That's good. I bet there's no broom involved. There isn't. Because the thing is, you know, all of these rituals, like the ones you're naming, they're usually tied to a specific type of haunting or bad luck or issue. And there are very specific rituals to rid yourself of an incubus. So, Esmeralda's psychic needed to get more specific with her.
Well, that's very specific. That's good. I bet there's no broom involved. There isn't. Because the thing is, you know, all of these rituals, like the ones you're naming, they're usually tied to a specific type of haunting or bad luck or issue. And there are very specific rituals to rid yourself of an incubus. So, Esmeralda's psychic needed to get more specific with her.|||好吧，这真的很具体。那挺好。我敢打赌里面肯定没有扫帚。确实没有。因为事情是这样的，你知道的，所有这些仪式，就像你刚才列举的那样，通常都与特定类型的闹鬼、厄运或问题相关。而要摆脱梦魇，则有非常具体的仪式。所以，埃斯梅拉达的灵媒需要给她更具体的指导。|||
Yeah, because it's. It doesn't include anything with garlic or salt. Right. Or burying something under a red rock with a full moon. I don't know where her psychic got this. If you find yourself with an incubus, everybody, here's what you can do. You can start with prayer. Exorcism.
Yeah, because it's. It doesn't include anything with garlic or salt. Right. Or burying something under a red rock with a full moon. I don't know where her psychic got this. If you find yourself with an incubus, everybody, here's what you can do. You can start with prayer. Exorcism.|||对，因为这……里面根本不包含任何大蒜或盐。没错。或者在满月之夜把什么东西埋在红石头下面。我不知道她的灵媒是从哪儿弄来这些说法的。各位，如果你发现自己被梦魇缠上了，你可以这样做。你可以从祈祷开始。驱魔。|||
You can cleanse your space with sage, incense, holy water, or blessed salt. I guess the salt has to be blessed. Because this is a demon. Right. An incubus is a demon. So you've got to get spiritual. Correct. You can also take a bath in the blessed salt.
You can cleanse your space with sage, incense, holy water, or blessed salt. I guess the salt has to be blessed. Because this is a demon. Right. An incubus is a demon. So you've got to get spiritual. Correct. You can also take a bath in the blessed salt.|||你可以用鼠尾草、熏香、圣水或开光盐来净化你的空间。我猜盐必须是开过光的。因为这是一只恶魔。没错。梦魇是一只恶魔。所以你必须动用精神力量。没错。你也可以泡一个开光盐浴。|||
Some folklore suggests that you should put a piece of cold iron such as scissors or a knife under your bed. I saw the iron thing in my list. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Also place your shoes facing away from the door. Don't know why. Okay. This one I was confused about.
Some folklore suggests that you should put a piece of cold iron such as scissors or a knife under your bed. I saw the iron thing in my list. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Also place your shoes facing away from the door. Don't know why. Okay. This one I was confused about.|||有些民间传说建议你把一块冷铁（比如剪刀或小刀）放在床底下。我在我的清单上也看到过铁制品这一项。嗯——哼。嗯——哼。还要把鞋子摆放成鞋尖朝外背对门的方向。不知道为什么。好吧。这一条让我感到很困惑。|||
I guess an incubus is afraid of their own reflection. So if you surround your bed with mirrors, it won't come into you at night while you're sleeping. That sounds kind of vampire-y. I know. Finally, use a dream catcher, but get a big one, a real big dream catcher, and maybe it'll catch the incubus before it can get into your dream. Have you ever done anything like this? I've saged my place before. on a sage. When I bought my house, I walked around and I saged it. I still have a ghost,
I guess an incubus is afraid of their own reflection. So if you surround your bed with mirrors, it won't come into you at night while you're sleeping. That sounds kind of vampire-y. I know. Finally, use a dream catcher, but get a big one, a real big dream catcher, and maybe it'll catch the incubus before it can get into your dream. Have you ever done anything like this? I've saged my place before. on a sage. When I bought my house, I walked around and I saged it. I still have a ghost,|||我猜梦魇害怕看到自己的倒影。所以如果你在床四周摆满镜子，它在你睡觉时就不会在夜里靠近你了。这听起来有点像对付吸 vampires（吸血鬼）的办法。我知道。最后，用捕梦网，但要买一个大的，一个真正的超大捕梦网，也许它能在梦魇进入你的梦境之前把它网住。你做过类似的事情吗？我以前用鼠尾草熏过我的住处。用鼠尾草。我买下房子时，拿着鼠尾草走遍了每个角落。我家里依然有一个鬼魂，|||
but she's friendly, so I'm okay with it. I've had hippie woo-woo friends come over and sage my places for me. Yeah. Same, Sam. One of my friends came over when I bought my house because it's an older house and she's like, well, first of all, we're going to sage it. So she did that. A week later, my mom and sister came out. They prayed over the house. So I've got everything covered. Yeah. That's good. Yeah. I think everywhere I live, I'm going to do both things. Yeah. Might as well. Might as well. Right? Good energy only here, people.
but she's friendly, so I'm okay with it. I've had hippie woo-woo friends come over and sage my places for me. Yeah. Same, Sam. One of my friends came over when I bought my house because it's an older house and she's like, well, first of all, we're going to sage it. So she did that. A week later, my mom and sister came out. They prayed over the house. So I've got everything covered. Yeah. That's good. Yeah. I think everywhere I live, I'm going to do both things. Yeah. Might as well. Might as well. Right? Good energy only here, people.|||但她很友好，所以我完全能接受。我曾让那些崇尚神秘主义的嬉皮士朋友来家里帮我用鼠尾草熏过。对啊。我也是，萨姆。我买房时，我的一位朋友也赶了过来，因为这是一栋老房子，她说：“好吧，首先我们要用鼠尾草熏一下。”于是她照做了。一周后，我妈妈和姐姐也来了。她们为这座房子祈了福。所以我这算是双管齐下了。对。那就好。对。我想我以后无论住在哪里，这两件事我都会做。对。没准儿还真有用。没准儿还真有用。对吧？这里只欢迎正能量，各位！|||
Agree. So we're back in the car and Mare is finishing talking to this writer from the Cleveland paper. And it really bumps Ned. Because basically, Mare says to the writer how hands off Ned is as the editor that she can just basically do whatever she wants. And he starts to say something, but then mayor is done with the conversation, hangs up the phone. I mean, she's intending it as a compliment because the writer is like, I'm surprised that with your paper's affiliation with softies that you were able to write this article. And she's like, oh, no, no, no, my editor, he's very hands-off. She makes a comment where she's like, I mean, I think the readers read the article before he did.
Agree. So we're back in the car and Mare is finishing talking to this writer from the Cleveland paper. And it really bumps Ned. Because basically, Mare says to the writer how hands off Ned is as the editor that she can just basically do whatever she wants. And he starts to say something, but then mayor is done with the conversation, hangs up the phone. I mean, she's intending it as a compliment because the writer is like, I'm surprised that with your paper's affiliation with softies that you were able to write this article. And she's like, oh, no, no, no, my editor, he's very hands-off. She makes a comment where she's like, I mean, I think the readers read the article before he did.|||同意。所以我们回到了车里，梅尔正在结束与这位克利夫兰报社记者的通话。这让内德非常郁闷。因为基本上，梅尔对记者说内德作为主编是多么地放权不管，她基本上可以为所欲为。他刚想说点什么，结果梅尔就结束了谈话，挂断了电话。我是说，她的本意是赞美，因为记者说：“我很惊讶，以你们报社和软派的关联，你竟然能写出这篇文章。”而梅尔则说：“哦，不，不，不，我的主编，他非常放权不管。”她还随口评价道：“我是说，我觉得读者读这篇文章的时候，他都还没读过呢。”|||
That's what really gets them. Yeah. Because then he doesn't seem hands-off like letting his reporters really have intents. then it seems like he's just half-assing it. Yeah. So they stop at a diner on their way. They haven't gotten to the cult place yet. They stop at a diner.
That's what really gets them. Yeah. Because then he doesn't seem hands-off like letting his reporters really have intents. then it seems like he's just half-assing it. Yeah. So they stop at a diner on their way. They haven't gotten to the cult place yet. They stop at a diner.|||这才是真正戳中他们痛点的地方。对啊。因为这样一来，他看起来就不像是那种大度放权、让记者真正发挥意图的主编了。看起来倒像是他根本在敷衍了事、马虎应付。对啊。于是他们在路边的一家小餐馆停了下来。他们还没到达那个邪教组织所在地。他们在一家餐馆停了下来。|||
And Ned decides, you know what? I want to review your questions. He's decided suddenly to take an interest in these questions she might ask. Because he had no interest before. Exactly. He was like, I trust you. Well, now he gets out a pen, a red pen. And he's like marking up the document.
And Ned decides, you know what? I want to review your questions. He's decided suddenly to take an interest in these questions she might ask. Because he had no interest before. Exactly. He was like, I trust you. Well, now he gets out a pen, a red pen. And he's like marking up the document.|||内德决定：“你知道吗？我想审阅一下你的问题。”他突然决定对她可能会问的这些问题产生兴趣了。因为他之前一点兴趣也没有。完全如此。他之前还一副“我相信你”的样子。好吧，现在他掏出了一支笔，一支红笔。开始在文件上涂涂改改。|||
Mm-hmm. Mayor does have a throwaway line here where she looks out the window and says, I think my dad took me to a pencil sharpener museum around here. Oh, yeah. I mean, come on, a pencil sharpener museum. Wait, is that real? It's real. Stop everything. Stop it.
Mm-hmm. Mayor does have a throwaway line here where she looks out the window and says, I think my dad took me to a pencil sharpener museum around here. Oh, yeah. I mean, come on, a pencil sharpener museum. Wait, is that real? It's real. Stop everything. Stop it.|||嗯哼。梅尔在这里有一句随口说的台词，她看着窗外说道：“我记得我爸爸以前带我去过这附近的铅笔刀博物馆。”哦，对。我是说，拜托，铅笔刀博物馆。等等，那是真的吗？是真的。停下手里所有的事。别闹了。|||
Yes, I had to be a lady who Googled again. This is so fun. There's a pencil sharpener museum in Logan, Ohio. And I went to the website. Here's what it says. stop by the Hawking Hills Regional Welcome Center and visit one of the more unique museums you will see, the Paul A. Johnson Pencil Sharpener Museum. Reverend Paul Johnson began his collection more than 20 years ago. It has over 3,400 pencil sharpeners, featured in national magazines. It's reputed to be the largest collection in America,
Yes, I had to be a lady who Googled again. This is so fun. There's a pencil sharpener museum in Logan, Ohio. And I went to the website. Here's what it says. stop by the Hawking Hills Regional Welcome Center and visit one of the more unique museums you will see, the Paul A. Johnson Pencil Sharpener Museum. Reverend Paul Johnson began his collection more than 20 years ago. It has over 3,400 pencil sharpeners, featured in national magazines. It's reputed to be the largest collection in America,|||是的，我又得扮演那个爱谷歌搜索的女士了。太有趣了。在俄亥俄州洛根市真的有一家铅笔刀博物馆。我访问了他们的网站。上面是这样写的：顺路造访霍金山地区游客中心，参观你能见到的最独特的博物馆之一——保罗·A·约翰逊铅笔刀博物馆。保罗·约翰逊牧师在20多年前开始了他的收藏。这里拥有超过3,400个铅笔刀，曾登上过国家级杂志。它据称是全美最大的铅笔刀收藏馆，|||
and recently they added Frank Parade's collection, and with those combined collections, there's an estimated 5,000 pencil. sharpeners. And there's pictures. You wouldn't believe the different types of pencil sharpeners. It's fascinating to me. I am actually feeling angry right now that I am 52 years old almost, and I'm only just learning about this pencil sharpener museum. Like, what? I need to go there, like soon. Do you love a pencil sharpener? No, I love museums of tiny things like pencil sharpeners. I love a pencil shirper. I love the randomness of this collection. There's pictures on the website, you guys.
and recently they added Frank Parade's collection, and with those combined collections, there's an estimated 5,000 pencil. sharpeners. And there's pictures. You wouldn't believe the different types of pencil sharpeners. It's fascinating to me. I am actually feeling angry right now that I am 52 years old almost, and I'm only just learning about this pencil sharpener museum. Like, what? I need to go there, like soon. Do you love a pencil sharpener? No, I love museums of tiny things like pencil sharpeners. I love a pencil shirper. I love the randomness of this collection. There's pictures on the website, you guys.|||最近他们又加入了弗兰克·帕雷德的藏品，将这些藏品合并后，估计一共有5,000个铅笔刀。上面还有图片。你绝对想不到铅笔刀会有这么多不同的款式。这对我太有吸引力了。我其实现在感到很生气，因为我都快52岁了，竟然才知道有这么个铅笔刀博物馆。简直了，什么情况？我得去那儿一趟，越快越好。你很喜欢铅笔刀吗？不，我喜欢收纳微小事物的博物馆，比如铅笔刀。我喜欢铅笔刀。我喜欢这个收藏系列那种随性又奇妙的感觉。网站上有图片哦，伙计们。|||
I'll share it in stories. Well, now Ned and Mayer are going to arrive at the fertile soil farm collective, and the camera crew can't come with them. They have to stay back. Yeah, Mayor says, quote, the cult dude is kind of secretive in an on-brand way. So they walk up, the cameras stay back, but you can see, people are all kind of doing yard work,
I'll share it in stories. Well, now Ned and Mayer are going to arrive at the fertile soil farm collective, and the camera crew can't come with them. They have to stay back. Yeah, Mayor says, quote, the cult dude is kind of secretive in an on-brand way. So they walk up, the cameras stay back, but you can see, people are all kind of doing yard work,|||我会在快拍里分享的。好了，现在内德和梅尔即将抵达“沃土农场公社”，而摄像团队不能跟他们一起去。他们必须留在后面。是的，梅尔说，引述原话：“那个邪教老兄神神秘秘的，很有他们的风格。”于是他们走了过去，摄像机留在后面，但你可以看到，人们都在那儿做着庭院杂务，|||
they're raking, and they're all wearing these red ponchos. Yeah, matching ponchos. I noted that Ned still has his yellow backpack from when we first met him in the first episode. I thought that was a nice callback. I have a missed opportunity alert here. Okay. How great would it have been if just one of the people in a red poncho was creed? Yes.
they're raking, and they're all wearing these red ponchos. Yeah, matching ponchos. I noted that Ned still has his yellow backpack from when we first met him in the first episode. I thought that was a nice callback. I have a missed opportunity alert here. Okay. How great would it have been if just one of the people in a red poncho was creed? Yes.|||他们正在扫落叶，而且他们都穿着这种红色的雨披。对，配套的雨披。我注意到内德依然背着他在第一集中我们刚见到他时背着的那个黄色背包。我觉得这是一个很棒的向前作致敬的细节。这里有一个“错失良机”警报。好的。如果穿红雨披的人当中哪怕只有一个人是克里德，那该有多棒啊？是的。|||
Come on, right, Sam? Thank you. Yes, yeah. We don't hear from him. Still with the beard from the last episode. Just a quick push in. Yeah. He doesn't even have to say anything.
Come on, right, Sam? Thank you. Yes, yeah. We don't hear from him. Still with the beard from the last episode. Just a quick push in. Yeah. He doesn't even have to say anything.|||拜托，对吧，萨姆？谢谢你。对的，没错。我们听不到他的声音。依然留着上一集里那大胡子。镜头只是快速推近一下。对。他甚至都不用说什么话。|||
He's just raking some leaves with the other people. Exactly. Yeah. That would have been great. I asked Dave Rogers, where did you shoot this? And he said it was the magic of filmmaking. They shot it on the universal back lot at a place that was a house that had some good trees and some good brush around it.
He's just raking some leaves with the other people. Exactly. Yeah. That would have been great. I asked Dave Rogers, where did you shoot this? And he said it was the magic of filmmaking. They shot it on the universal back lot at a place that was a house that had some good trees and some good brush around it.|||他只是和其他人一起扫扫落叶。完全正确。对。那可就太棒了。我问戴夫·罗杰斯：“你们是在哪里拍这一段的？”他说这就是电影制作的魔术。他们是在环球影城的后景场（back lot）拍摄的，那是一个带有不错树木和灌木丛的房子。|||
He said the art department did it. a great job making it look like a farm. And I can't believe that this was shot on the lot. This is like just blowing my mind. I know we're kind of a broken record here, but you guys, when we went to Shrewd farms, we went to a freaking farm an hour outside of L.A., we had to have a rattlesnake wrangler because there were rattlesnakes everywhere. We had to leave our houses at 4.30 in the morning. I mean, I guess that's what you get when you shoot on a big time real deal, old Hollywood lot, which is amazing. They have all these different nooks and crannies that look like New York City or an old town square
He said the art department did it. a great job making it look like a farm. And I can't believe that this was shot on the lot. This is like just blowing my mind. I know we're kind of a broken record here, but you guys, when we went to Shrewd farms, we went to a freaking farm an hour outside of L.A., we had to have a rattlesnake wrangler because there were rattlesnakes everywhere. We had to leave our houses at 4.30 in the morning. I mean, I guess that's what you get when you shoot on a big time real deal, old Hollywood lot, which is amazing. They have all these different nooks and crannies that look like New York City or an old town square|||他说美术部门把这里布置得真像个农场。我真不敢相信这竟然是在片场拍的。这简直让我大开眼界。我知道我们在这儿有点像老生常谈了，但各位，当年我们去“精明农场”拍摄时，我们去了离洛杉矶一小时车程的一个货真价实的农场，我们还得配备一个响尾蛇捕捉员，因为到处都是响尾蛇。我们不得不早上4点30分离开家。我是说，我想这就是在那种老牌、真正的、老好莱坞大片场拍摄所能享受到的待遇，太棒了。他们拥有各种各样看起来像纽约市或老镇广场的角落和缝隙|||
or a farm. And we just shot in this tiny soundstage in Van Nuys, so we had to travel. If we had to show any part of the world, we had to get out. We had to load up in a van and go on the road and watch out for rattlesnakes. Yep. Or a bee in John's eggs. Correct. Well, back at the truth teller.
or a farm. And we just shot in this tiny soundstage in Van Nuys, so we had to travel. If we had to show any part of the world, we had to get out. We had to load up in a van and go on the road and watch out for rattlesnakes. Yep. Or a bee in John's eggs. Correct. Well, back at the truth teller.|||或者农场的地方。而我们只能在范奈司的一个极小的摄影棚里拍摄，所以我们必须到处奔波。如果我们必须展现世界的任何一个角落，我们就必须走出去。我们必须挤上面包车上路，还要提防响尾蛇。没错。或者约翰的鸡蛋里有只蜜蜂。完全正确。好了，镜头回到《真理报》。|||
Oscar announces he has discovered who the troll is. I guess he called the IT department after all. He did. Guess what? It's coming from inside the building. It's coming from Anne Putnam's office. Marv's assistant and sister-in-law, Anne. They cannot believe this.
Oscar announces he has discovered who the troll is. I guess he called the IT department after all. He did. Guess what? It's coming from inside the building. It's coming from Anne Putnam's office. Marv's assistant and sister-in-law, Anne. They cannot believe this.|||奥斯卡宣布他已经查出那个网络喷子是谁了。我猜他最终还是给IT部门打电话了。他确实打了。你猜怎么着？这个IP来自大楼内部。来自安·帕特南的办公室。马尔的助理兼小姨子安。他们简直不敢相信这件事。|||
But Oscar has a talking head that's great where he says it makes sense. Let's hear it. I see it often. in people over 50. They get trapped in the year that they join Facebook. It's as if the technology sends their brain into shock and their online personalities get frozen in time. So Anne is basically a snarky millennial
But Oscar has a talking head that's great where he says it makes sense. Let's hear it. I see it often. in people over 50. They get trapped in the year that they join Facebook. It's as if the technology sends their brain into shock and their online personalities get frozen in time. So Anne is basically a snarky millennial|||但奥斯卡有一段非常精彩的个人独白，他说这一切都讲得通。我们来听听。我在50岁以上的人身上经常看到这种现象。他们被困在了自己加入脸书（Facebook）的那一年。就好像这项技术让他们的大脑陷入了休克，他们的网络人格就此定格在了那个时间里。所以安基本上就是一个尖酸刻薄的千禧一代，|||
trapped in the body of a boomer. That is such a funny description. I think there's some real truth in it. There might be. And look, I know my sister Janet listens to the podcast But Janet, the emojis you use are very telling to me when you started having like the smartphone thing. Why? I only use a handful of emojis.
trapped in the body of a boomer. That is such a funny description. I think there's some real truth in it. There might be. And look, I know my sister Janet listens to the podcast But Janet, the emojis you use are very telling to me when you started having like the smartphone thing. Why? I only use a handful of emojis.|||却被困在了婴儿潮一代的躯壳里。这个形容太搞笑了。我觉得这里面确实有几分真理。也许吧。听着，我知道我妹妹珍妮会听这个播客。但是，珍妮，你用的那些表情符号对我来说非常说明问题，也就是从你开始拥有智能手机之类东西的时候起。为什么？我只用那么几个表情符号。|||
And I think it's because early on there were only a few to choose from. And now there's so many. I only use face palm, heart, and like the person who's crying while they laugh. See, I think that shows when you joined the sort of smartphone thing, right? Sam? What about you? I am partial to the guy giving the salute. Oh. It's a good. I've heard your sentence and I want to not give input to the conversation, wrap it up.
And I think it's because early on there were only a few to choose from. And now there's so many. I only use face palm, heart, and like the person who's crying while they laugh. See, I think that shows when you joined the sort of smartphone thing, right? Sam? What about you? I am partial to the guy giving the salute. Oh. It's a good. I've heard your sentence and I want to not give input to the conversation, wrap it up.|||我想那是因为早期可供选择的表情符号本来就不多。而现在却有这么多。我只用捂脸、爱心，还有那个一边笑一边哭的人。你看，我觉得这恰恰说明了你是什么时候加入智能手机时代这拨儿的，对吧？萨姆？你呢？我比较偏爱那个敬礼的表情包。哦。这是一个很好的表情。意思是“我听完你的话了，但我想对这场对话保持沉默，赶紧结束吧”。|||
emoji. I use the smiley face that has the like straight line smile of all teeth. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Angela, I'm constantly using that one because I always feel that way. Yeah. Or I use the lady in the red dress running. Yeah.
表情符号。我用那个咧嘴笑、露出一排牙齿的。哦，对。安吉拉，我一直在用那个，因为我总是那种感觉。对。或者我用那个穿红裙子奔跑的女士。对。
You love that one. I love that one. That's that four. That's like, party. I think it's just like, I'm a badass. I'm running my dress. Isn't she dancing? I think she is.
你超爱那个。我也超爱那个。那是第四个。那就像是，派对。我觉得它就像是，我很厉害。我在穿着裙子跑步。她不是在跳舞吗？我觉得她是。
But like my sister Janet will do like the hand emojis that's like thumbs up. Then I love you. Then peace, fingers, and then like a hamburger, a glass of wine, champagne. Well, the thumbs up just reads his passive aggressive. That's like texting. No, but she's not. She's not passive aggressive. Okay.
但比如我姐姐珍妮会用那种手势表情符号，就像竖起大拇指。然后我爱你。然后是比耶的手势，然后像个汉堡、一杯葡萄酒、香槟。嗯，竖起大拇指看起来就像是消极抵抗。那就好像发短信。不，但她不是。她不是消极抵抗。好吧。
I was just reading how people want to cancel the thumbs up. because people think it's passive-aggressive. And I was like, oh, no, that's my most common one. Oh, I do thumbs up all the time. This is all used to me. Me and my dad wouldn't talk if we didn't do thumbs-up emojis. Oh, yeah. It's a perfect dad and son emoji.
我刚刚看到一篇文章说人们想取消竖起大拇指的表情。因为人们觉得这是消极抵抗。然后我想，哦，不，这是我最常用的一个。哦，我一直在用竖起大拇指。这对我来说太习以为常了。我和我爸如果不发竖起大拇指的表情，我们俩就没法聊天了。哦，对。这是完美的父子表情符号。
I'll give you that. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. Maybe it's time to throw some new ones in our emoji resume, guys. You know what? I want to put this out there in our office ladies text thread, feel free to try on new
我承认这一点。好吧。对。对。不知道。也许是时候在我们的表情符号简历里加入一些新的了，伙计们。你知道吗？我想在我们的办公室女郎短信群里提出来，大家可以随意尝试新的
emojis, no judgment. Yeah. It's our safe space to try new things. I can't wait. I can't wait. Well, now we're going to go back to fertile soil. They're leaving. They're getting in their car. And Ned has decided they're not a cult. Mayor thinks they are a cult. Mayor's like, you didn't let me ask any hard-hitting questions. And they get into a car and they're just annoyed with each other. Yeah. And this back and forth about whether or not they're a cult or not follows them back onto their drive home. It did make me wonder could the right cult, Colt get you. This was a question Ned asks early on. Right. Because I kind of joined a cult once on accident. And being your friend all these years, I want to say this is really on brand. I think
表情符号，绝对不评判。对。这是我们尝试新事物的安全空间。我等不及了。我等不及了。好吧，现在我们要回到肥沃的土地上。他们要离开了。他们上了车。内德决定他们不是一个邪教。梅尔觉得他们是一个邪教。梅尔觉得：你都没让我问任何尖锐的问题。然后他们上车了，彼此看对方很不爽。对。而关于他们到底是不是邪教的争论一直伴随着他们开车回家。这确实让我怀疑，合适的邪教会不会把你拉进去。这是内德早期提出的一个问题。对。因为我曾经不小心加入过一个邪教。而且认识你这么多年，我想说这真的太符合你的特质了。我觉得
when people first meet us, Sam, maybe you would think I'm the one that would fall prey to a cult. No, not at all. Actually, Jenna. Well, this is also how I accidentally joined a call girl ring. because I thought I had joined a singing group. Yes. You're oddly, like, very susceptible to these groups. I am. Yeah. And you're such a critical thinker.
当人们第一次见到我们时，萨姆，也许你会认为我是那种会落入邪教圈套的人。不，完全不会。其实，珍妮。好吧，这也是我如何不小心加入一个陪酒女郎团伙的。因为我以为我加入了一个歌唱团伙。是的。你莫名其妙地非常容易受到这些团伙的影响。我是。对。而你明明是个很有批判性思维的人。
I know. And yet, I also believe a ghost lives in my closet, lady. I don't know. Well, lady, if you ever get sucked in by a cult, I'd come and get you. Thank you. I know that you will. You're welcome. That's best friendship.
我知道。然而，我也相信我的衣柜里住着一个鬼魂，女士。我不知道。好吧，女士，如果你真的被邪教卷进去了，我会去救你的。谢谢。我知道你会的。不客气。这就是最好的友谊。
Mm-hmm. Well, now as they're arguing and driving down the road, Mary gets a flat tire. Yes, they're going to have to change this tire. Mayor is going to change it. Ned's just like sitting in the back of the trunk. Like, do you know how hard it is to ratchet up your car in the first place and he's just sitting in the back?
嗯。好吧，现在当他们在路上争吵并开车时，梅尔的车胎爆了。是的，他们得换轮胎了。梅尔来换。内德就坐在后备箱后面。就好像，你知不知道一开始用千斤顶把车撑起来有多难，而他却只坐在后面？
Oh, yeah. What the heck, Ned? What the heck, Ned. I do have a wardrobe catch here. What is it? 15 minutes, 25 seconds. I absolutely loved the boots that mare is wearing. so I had to Google them.
哦，天哪。搞什么鬼，内德？搞什么鬼，内德。我这里有一个服装穿帮。是什么？15分25秒。我太喜欢梅尔穿的靴子了，所以我不得不去谷歌搜索一下。
I went on to one of the websites I used to check costume and wardrobe stuff. Shop YourTV.com says they are the six-inch classic mock women's short boot and black boundary leather by Red Wing. Oh, are they expensive? They retail for $319.99. But they are really cool looking. You want to see? Yeah. Oh, those are super cool.
我去了我以前常看服装和戏服的一个网站。Shop YourTV.com说那是Red Wing品牌的六英寸经典莫克女式短靴，采用黑色边界皮革。哦，它们贵吗？零售价是319.99美元。但它们看起来真的很酷。你想看看吗？对。哦，那些超级酷。
I know. Yeah. Those are really cool. I know. I kind of want a pair now. If I were Chelsea, I would ask to take those home at the end of the season. I hope she gets them. Well, I asked Dave Rogers where they shot this, and guess what?
我知道。对。那些真的很酷。我知道。我现在有点想要一双了。如果我是切尔西，我会在季末要求把那些带回家。我希望她能拿到。好吧，我问过戴夫·罗杰斯他们是在哪里拍这一幕的，你猜怎么着？
Also on the universal back lot. They found a street on the lot just right around the corner from that house that was being the farm. And I mean, this is crazy. This street on the universal back lot had a hill because Mary's going to get mad at Ned and she's going to roll the tire down this hill and make him chase after it. I can't believe that was on the universal backlog. I can't either. That lot is huge, though.
也是在环球影城的后外景地。他们在那个农场房子的拐角处找到了一条街道。我的天，这太疯狂了。环球影城后外景地的这条街居然有一个坡，因为梅尔要对内德生气，她要把轮胎顺着这个坡滚下去，让他追着跑。我不敢相信那是环球影城的后外景地。我也这么觉得。不过那个外景地真的很大。
It goes on and on. Well, this is true. Well, now here's a moment of truth. Oscar and the rest of the gang are going to go confront Anne about her snarky comments. Mm-hmm. And the character of Anne could win a little Oscar here. She really could. She's like, what?
无边无际。好吧，这是真的。好吧，现在是见证真相的时刻了。奥斯卡和其余的人要去当面质问安妮那些刻薄的评论。嗯。而安妮这个角色在这里可以拿个小金人奖。她真的可以。她就像是，什么？
Who would do such awful things? And then she's like, oh, dang it. Marv has told me I need to set a password, and I just thought who would ever just come on my computer and do something like that. I just feel horrible. And they're just like, oh, no, it's okay. It's okay. They believe her. I know she's like they shouldn't give people my age these machines.
谁会做出这么可怕的事？然后她又说，哦，该死。马尔告诉我要设置一个密码，我刚才还在想怎么会有人直接用我的电脑做出这种事。我真是觉得糟糕透了。然后他们就说，哦，不，没关系。没关。他们相信了她。我知道，她就像是在说，他们不该把这种机器交给我这个年纪的人。
Yeah. She completely convinces them that she had nothing to do with it. And they all leave. And then she has this talking head where she says, you know what? whoever the troll is probably just wants to hold the truth teller to a high standard of quality. Marv has invested a lot of money, so they need to make sure it's awesome sauce. So it is Anne. It is Anne.
对。她彻底说服了他们，让他们觉得这事跟她一点关系都没有。然后他们都离开了。接着她有一段独白，她说，你知道吗？不管那个喷子是谁，可能只是想对真相传播者抱有很高的品质标准。马尔投资了很多钱，所以他们需要确保这个节目棒极了。所以确实是安妮。就是安妮。
Do you think she'll keep doing it? Yeah, I do. I do too. Well, Ned and Mayer have changed their tire, and they're stopping at this diner again on their way home. Ned tries to make a peace offering to Mayor. He gets her this ice cream float. But he only buys one, and it's only for mayor. And so they get in this crazy, weird fight about who should eat this ice cream soda and go back and forth about it.
你觉得她会继续这样做吗？对，我觉得会。我也这么觉得。好吧，内德和梅尔换好了轮胎，他们在回家的路上又在这个小餐馆停了下来。内德试图向梅尔求和。他给她买了这个冰淇淋漂浮饮料。但他只买了一份，而且是专门买给梅尔的。于是他们为谁该吃这个冰淇淋苏打水展开了一场疯狂而奇怪的争吵，推来推去。
It's very childish. Yeah. Dave shared that there was a fun bit of improv during this scene that he wished would have made it in. There was this moment, I guess, where Donal improvised actually, eating the ice cream float. Like, he's like, fine, Mayor, I'll eat it. And he downs it in like four spoonfuls. And then Mayor is shocked.
这非常幼稚。对。戴夫分享说，这一幕中有一个很有趣的即兴发挥，他希望当时能保留下来。好像有这样一个时刻，唐纳尔即兴发挥，真的把冰淇淋漂浮饮料给吃了。就好像他说，好吧，梅尔，我来吃。然后他用了四勺就把它们全吞下去了。接着梅尔惊呆了。
And then he continues to try to make his case with her, but he has to stop because he has brain freeze. Dave said it was such good improv. He thought it was so funny. He put it in his director's cut, but ultimately got taken out. Aw. But he loved it.
然后他继续试图向她解释，但他不得不停下来，因为他脑子冻结了（大脑因吃冰冷食物而短暂疼痛）。戴夫说这个即兴太棒了。他觉得太搞笑了。他把它放进了导演剪辑版里，但最终还是被删掉了。啊。但他很喜欢。
Maybe they'll get to do super fan versions of the paper. Superfan. versions of the peacock version. Yes. They can add even more. Yeah. Well, Ned and Mayer are still bickering and they're back in the parking lot now.
也许他们能有机会做《The Paper》的超级粉丝版本。超级粉丝版本的孔雀（Peacock）版本。对。他们可以加入更多内容。对。好吧，内德和梅尔还在斗嘴，他们现在又回到了停车场。
They're going to get in the car to drive back home. When Ned gets a phone call, it's Detrick calling to tell them they were nominated for the Ohio Journalism Awards. Yes. Mayor is nominated for her Softie's Clog's Toledo story, but the entire paper is
他们正要上车开车回家。这时内德接到了一个电话，是代特里克打来的，通知他们入围了俄亥俄州新闻奖。是的。梅尔因她的“软拖鞋托莱多”报道而入围，但整个报社都
up for the overall excellence in journalism. And they are just elated. Yes. They do a little happy dance in the parking lot. So I guess all is forgiven there. I mean, this is very exciting. Big news. Mm-hmm.
入围了新闻卓越综合大奖。他们欣喜若狂。是的。他们在停车场跳起了一段快乐的舞。所以我想那里的所有恩怨都一笔勾销了。我的意思是，这非常令人兴奋。大新闻。嗯。
And you know, the next episode, the season finale, is the Ohio Journalism Awards. We're going to see how this all plays out. But this episode is going to end with Esmeralda walking into the office and she just walks over to Barry's desk and she just gives them a big kiss on the lips. Yes. And then she says this whole speech where she's like, you have been kissed on the 17th day of the month. I command you to forsake me. Set me free.
你知道，下一集，也就是季终集，就是俄亥俄州新闻奖。我们要看看这一切将如何收场。但这一集将以埃斯梅拉达走进办公室结束，她径直走到巴里的桌子前，直接重重地亲吻了巴里的嘴唇。是的。然后她发表了一长串演讲，大意是：你在当月的第17天被亲吻了。我命令你抛弃我。还我自由。
Set me free. Set me free. And then she's like, the spell is broken. And Barry's like, okay. I loved it. One last thing I want to share from Dave Rogers. I thought this was so sweet. He said one of the highlights of the week of him directing this episode
还我自由。还我自由。然后她说，魔咒解除了。巴里就说，好吧。我太喜欢了。我想分享来自戴夫·罗杰斯的最后一件事。我觉得这太甜蜜了。他说他执导这一周的亮点之一
was that they got some very extra special VIPs that came to set. Jenna, you mentioned this. These are Dave's words, not ours. He said, the lovely Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, who I might add got a huge round of applause from the cast and crew when they stepped onto the set. Some of the cast told me later they were both excited and nervous to meet you, but it was so nice having you guys there
就是他们迎来了几位非常特别的VIP来到片场。珍妮，你提到过这个。这是戴夫的原话，不是我们的。他说，可爱的珍妮·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西，我得补充一句，当她们走进片场时，受到了演员和剧组人员的热烈掌声。一些演员后来告诉我，他们见到你们既兴奋又紧张，但有你们在那里真是太好了
and those of us who worked on the office like Greg, Rusty, Kelly, Keisha, Veda, Steve, and Lori and Sergio, and of course Oscar were really thrilled and so happy to see you. guys. Aw. That was really special. We both teared up. It was such a great group of people.
而且我们这些在《办公室》工作过的人，比如格雷格、拉斯蒂、凯利、基莎、维达、史蒂夫、洛里、塞尔吉奥，当然还有奥斯卡，都感到非常激动，看到你们大家真的很高兴。啊。这真的很特别。我们俩都热泪盈眶。这是一群太棒的人了。
Yeah. Well, you guys, thank you so much for listening to today's episode and for sending in your questions, your comments, your chit chats, you're around the towns. And of course, a huge thank you to Dave Rogers for giving us behind the scenes details. Dave would like you to know that the season nine superfan episodes of The Office are up on Peacock right now. You know, he works so hard on them. And we're going to talk more about those in a few episodes, but they're really special. And of course, a big thank you to Chelsea Fry. Oh, my God, we loved watching you in this episode. Thanks for always texting us back when we DM you.
对。好吧，伙计们，非常感谢你们收听今天的节目，感谢你们发来你们的问题、评论、闲聊、社区八卦。当然，非常感谢戴夫·罗杰斯为我们提供幕后细节。戴夫想让你们知道，《办公室》第九季的孔雀网超级粉丝版现在已经在Peacock上线了。你知道，他为之付出了巨大的努力。我们会在接下来的几集里更多地讨论这些，它们真的非常特别。当然，还要非常感谢切尔西·弗莱。哦，天哪，我们太喜欢看你在这一集里的表现了。谢谢你在我们私信你时总是回信息。
All right, everyone, we love you. And we will see you next week. And we should mention that next week we'll be breaking down the finale episode of The Paper with Chelsea Fry. In the story, studio. Yeah, so be sure to join us for that one. We love you guys. See you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is Produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了，各位，我们爱你们。我们下周见。我们应该提一下，下周我们将和切尔西·弗莱一起剖析《The Paper》的最后一集。在故事工作室。对，所以请务必加入我们。我们爱你们。下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女郎》。《办公室女郎》是奥迪赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍妮·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。奥迪赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女郎》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。